Der 14. Spieltag in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Er ist gespielt, der November ist vorbei. Wir wollen auf die 2. Liga schauen und das mit Anna Lautenbach und Michael Fischer. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja, willkommen zurück zur Ligatour, zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ihr könnt mich sonst in meinen Freunden am Abendpodcast hören oder in der Sendung von Heute Morgen zur Bundesliga der Männer. Witzig. Ja, aber mache heute den Podcast-Hat-Trick voll und deshalb auch der kleine, aber feine Hinweis, wenn ihr mich hier zwischendurch mal kurz husten seht oder so, es ist so die Kombination aus Winter, Derby und dritter Podcast heute tue nicht das Beste für meine Stimme. Von daher bin ich da etwas, ja, angekratzt. Aber ich muss ja glücklicherweise diese Sendung nicht alleine machen, sondern ich begrüße euch und meine Gäste zur letzten regulären Folge mit All-Star-Teammitgliedern in diesem Jahr. Was es damit auf sich hat, das erkläre ich euch gleich noch. Und damit welcome back an Anna Lautenbach vom Gegengarde Podcast. Hallo Anna.
Schönen guten Abend. Ich freue mich sehr.
Ja, und ein, ich glaube, sehr gut gelaunten Michael Fischer von den Nürnberger Nachrichten und dem Fürther Flachpass. Hallo Michi.
Hallo Eva. Hallo Anna. Hallo liebe Menschen da draußen. Ich melde mich vom Abgrund, in dem wir dann gleich gemeinsam schauen.
Es ist eine, es wird eine fantastische Folge. Lass uns, bevor wir reingehen in die Besprechung der einzelnen Vereine, einmal kurz auf die Themen gucken, die noch so wichtig waren an diesem Spieltag. Und Anna, ich frage einfach mal dich, was beschäftigt dich da und hat es zufälligerweise etwas mit einem Spiel am Samstagmittag zu tun?
Ja, du, ihr werdet das Gefühl, denke ich, kennen, dass ein Spiele, wie ich sie am Samstagmittag erleben durfte, viel weniger beschäftigen als die Spiele, die ich davor in den Wochen sehen und erleben musste. Ja, also es ist ja immer ein bisschen was Besonderes. Wir haben gegen den 1. FC Kaiserslautern gespielt mit Thorsten Lieberknecht an der Seitenlinie, mit der in Braunschweig tatsächlich– und ich glaube, das muss man auch erst mal schaffen– maximal auf ungerne stößt und nicht auf verpisst dich, du Schimpfwort einfügen. Ja, genau, also insofern immer warmes Willkommen. Es war ein Einmal-Löwe-Immer-Löwe in der 12. Minute. Ich glaube, das ist ganz in Ordnung. Ansonsten würde ich sagen, beste Saisonleistung gegen schlechteste Saisonleistung, zumindest den Stimmen in den Interviews nach dem Spiel und in der PK zu entnehmen. Thorsten Lieberknecht sehr unzufrieden, Heiner Backhaus eher zufrieden. Werden wir im Verlauf der Folge wahrscheinlich auch noch darauf zu sprechen kommen. Das ist so ein bisschen das Lied, das der erste FCM im Moment auch singt. Eigentlich war es nicht anders als in den Wochen davor. Nur diesmal haben wir gewonnen. Ja, was das jetzt für die Zukunft heißt, mal gucken. Wenn alle fit bleiben, hoffe ich, dass ich weiterhin am Montag an etwas anderes denken kann als Ärger über Fußball. Aber aus dem Fenster möchte ich mich noch nicht lehnen.
Man muss ja auch fast sagen, schön, dass es mal keine rote Karte gab, bevor man sich, glaube ich, in diesem Spiel auch nicht hätte beschweren dürfen. Ja, genau.
Es ist genau das tatsächlich. Also Robin Häusler hätte absolut vom Platz gestellt werden können, für einen an diesem Hals-Schulter-Bereich ziehen und den Lauterer-Spieler umreißen. Seine Interpretation war, er hat den Ball gespielt und den Spieler dabei berührt. Aber ich glaube, da gibt es unterschiedliche Lesarten.
Das ist sehr interessant, aber man muss auch sagen, ich glaube, nach über 270 Minuten ohne eigenes Tor auch endlich mal wieder Tor geschossen. Also ich finde, man konnte wirklich sehen, dass dieses 1-0 so eine Effektwirkung auch einfach auf das ganze Team hatte. Man hat sich irgendwie doch dann vielleicht noch die ein oder andere Chance erarbeitet, die auch in den letzten Wochen und Monaten vielleicht auch einfach nicht so drin war. Aber er bringt natürlich auch nochmal ordentlich Aufwind da unten mit rein. Also generell zeigt man wieder, da kann sich keiner drauf ausruhen, dass die Vereine unter einem nicht punkten. Es wird da immer wieder Teams geben, die da eben ihre Punkte sammeln. Dafür ist es– ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da immer so gerne– aber alles viel zu eng beieinander und natürlich vor allem in dieser Phase der Saison. Michi, was gab es denn für dich so ein Spiel, was dich mitgenommen hat außerhalb des Spiels am Samstagmittag?
Ja, am Freitag wusste ich glücklicherweise noch nicht, was am Samstagmittag passieren würde, aber dass der FC Schalke jetzt schon wieder gewinnt, dass er auch den SC Paderborn zu Hause schlägt, dass er– wie du, Eva, weißt– Brian, lass mich natürlich, klar– der geborene Stürmer, der Schalke zum Sieg schießt– dass der FC Schalke 2-1 gegen Paderborn gewinnt, Tabellenführer ist es das eine, dass er mit 18 Toren, damit zwei weniger als der Tabellen-17, nämlich die Spielvereinigung aus Fürth, 31 Punkte geholt hat, 18 mehr, wenn ich mich erinnere. Fürth ist schon das eine, aber es zeigt, wohin man mit einer stabilen Defensive in der 2. Liga kopiert, das sind erst 8 Gegentore in 14 Spielen. Ich glaube, man kann es Minimalprinzip nennen, das ist einfach extrem stark defensiv, muss man sagen. Damit gewinnt man halt an Spiele, oft gewinnt man sie auch 1-0. Ich war bei einem 1-0 des FC Schalke auch im Stadion. Damit diese Wucht immer noch spürt, dieses Vereins, diese 60.000, die da sind, diese Begeisterung, wenn man in dieses Stadion geht, auch ums Stadion herum, das ist alles bundesliga-tauglich. Jetzt ist auch der Fußball zumindest mal dem Ergebnis ein Nachrieder. Und auch von der Begeisterungsfähigkeit bundesliga-tauglich. Irgendwie hat Kees van Wonderen mal gesagt, er ist kein Harry Potter, aber Miron Muzlic ist es anscheinend. Also er kann offenbar diesen Standort dann schon wieder verzaubern und zu neuen Höhenflügen führen. Und das eine ist ja das Fußballerische, das andere ist auch so die Kommunikation, die an so großen Standorten, wo es irgendwie gerne mal zwischen ganz grau und alles ganz toll hin und her schwankt, ganz wichtig. Und dass Miran Muslic auch dafür der perfekte Trainer ist, spürt man eigentlich jede Woche. Er macht das extrem gut kommunikativ und er ist halt einfach auch extrem empathisch. Am Wochenende gab es eine Situation, die vielleicht auch einige Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen haben, dass Justin Hekaren, der Ersatzzeug, der noch verletzt nach dem Spiel mit einer Fahne sich an einen verstorbenen Freund, der auch Schalker war, erinnert hat. Und dann hat Muslic ihm von hinten den Arm um die Brust gelegt und ihn heftig in den Arm genommen. Also das sind auch so kleine Gesten, die einfach zeigen, dieser Mensch ist anscheinend ein sehr großer. Und wenn der FC Schalke zum Bundesliga-Aufstieg führt, dann wird er vermutlich für alle Menschen rund um Gelsenkirchen und dem Ruhrpott der größte sein.
Ja, liebe Grüße an Nele Hüpper, die heute Morgen erzählt hat, dass Schalke Fan ihrerseits und Teil des Allstar-Teams, die erzählt hat, dass wenn Schalke aufsteigt, dass sie sich dann eine Katze holt und sie Miron nennt. Also, auch schön. Ich muss einfach sagen, was mich bei dem Spiel so überrascht hat, Paderborn in Führung ist auch schon echt eine Macht. Und wir haben sonst eigentlich immer gesehen, wie Schalke selbst in Führung agiert und das dann wirklich ein sehr schwieriges zu bespielendes Team ist und dass sie jetzt sogar es eben schaffen, dieses Spiel zu drehen, spricht halt irgendwie. Also, sie können halt gerade alles, ehrlich gesagt. Und das ist natürlich schon, ich sag mal, keine gute Nachricht für alle anderen Teams.
Ja, wir können uns ja, glaube ich, einigen, dass dieser Standort schon, auch wenn viel in den letzten Jahren falsch gelaufen ist, die Bundesliga verdient hat. Insofern freut es mich auch, wenn ich in die größten Sympathien für den FC Schalke hege.
Ja, und natürlich auch rein finanziell gesehen. Ich glaube, man hat jetzt eine Anleihe nochmal ausgelöst und konnte da eben Verbindlichkeiten tilgen, wo man und auch mehr, als man erst gedacht hatte. Also, da war eine sehr erfolgreiche Anleihe, die man über Anleihstopp hinaus, glaube ich, auf 90 Millionen Euro oder so heben konnte. Also, sehr großer Erfolg da. Wir haben ja schon lang und breit mal über die finanziellen Probleme vom FC Schalke gesprochen. Von daher, man kann wirklich nur dem Standort wünschen, dass da alles drum herum ein nachhaltigen Weg jetzt mal geht. Weil wir wissen auch, es bringt auch nichts, wenn du irgendwie mit ein bisschen Glück und ohne wirklichen Plan in die Zukunft in die Bundesliga aufsteigst. Als FC Schalke vor allem. Das geht dann ganz schnell in die andere Richtung. Vielleicht noch der Vollständigkeit halber. Hertha gewinnt auch das fünfte Spiel in Folge gegen Kiel. Sie gewinnen immer mehr Spiele, wo man sagt, wenn man das gewinnt, dann Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Ich muss sagen, es tut mir leid, Marc. Ich bin noch nicht vollständig im Hype-Train angekommen. Sie holen inzwischen die Ergebnisse, dass ich erwarte, dass sie holen. Gleichzeitig bei Kiel natürlich. Mehr Fragezeichen weiterhin, glaube ich, so ein bisschen ob des Saisonsverlaufs. Elbersberg und Darmstadt, die hatten nicht so viel Bock auf Tore. Das waren 0-0 im Gegensatz zu dem Top-Spiel vom Freitagabend. Denn eher ein etwas langweiligeres Spiel. Und natürlich Preuß Münster gewinnt das Derby gegen Bielefeld. Und damit das erste Mal ein Pflichtspiel nach der Alm seit 31 Jahren. Ich wünschte, ich wäre nicht dabei gewesen. Alles weitere, was ich zu diesem Spiel zu sagen habe, lege ich freiwillig unter den Mantel des Schweigens. Weil ich weiß nicht, wie viele möglicherweise strafrechtlich relevante Dinge dabei sonst noch sind. Das möchtet ihr alle nicht. Und das möchte ich vor allem nicht. Ich möchte noch ein bisschen Host dieses Formats sein. Und dann bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Markus Mann bleibt in Hannover. Es gab eine Anfrage vom VfL Wolfsburg. Da scheinen die Niedersachsens gedacht zu haben. Gucken wir einfach mal im eigenen Revier. Das war nicht erfolgreich. Wir haben uns natürlich auch in der 2. Liga bundesweit proteste gegen die IMK. Das war ja etwas, was sich die letzten zwei Wochenenden eben auch in der 2. Liga durchgesetzt hat. Bei einer Partie sogar noch Besonderheit. Und auf die kommen wir jetzt tatsächlich zu sprechen. Einfach Queen auf Überleitung hier. Haha. Ich erkläre euch einmal den Höhrenden einmal, was wir uns hier für heute ausgedacht haben. Weil wir dachten, immer nur über Abstiegskampf und Aufstiegskampf zu sprechen ist irgendwie ein bisschen langweilig. Und wir haben uns im Vorhinein auf drei Partien geeinigt, über die wir sprechen wollen. Und ich würde uns drei einfach mal selbst loben. Wir haben uns dafür durchaus ereignisreiche Partien entschieden. Es waren wie gesagt drei Partien. Einmal sprechen wir über Magdeburg gegen Nürnberg, über Fürth gegen Bochum und Dresden gegen Düsseldorf. Also ja, ich weiß, da ist auch viel aus dem Abstiegskampf dabei. Aber wir haben da immer so ganz schöne Klammern im Endeffekt dann. Und wir wollen starten im Osten beim 1. FCM-Spiel. Das geht relativ überraschend. 3 zu 0 aus für den FCM gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg. Doppelpack zu Kowski, nein nicht der mit der Weihnachtsbäckerei, der andere in der 73. und 90. plus 5. Bräunig dann in der 90. plus 10. Es gab 20 Minuten Nachspielzeit wegen Pyrotechnikunterbrechung Anfang der zweiten Hälfte. Vermeintlicher Doppelpack auch noch für Bräunig, gab da aber allerdings eine Abseits-Stellung von Bochorn. Magdeburg auf Platz 18 mit 10 Punkten, 13 zu 24 Toren. Man hat die schlechteste Offensive der Liga, gemeinsam mit Fortuna Düsseldorf. 3 Siege, ein Unentschieden und 10 Niederlagen. Patrick Sander, der hat den FCM von Markus Wiedler am 9. Spieltag übernommen, gab in der Liga seitdem zwei Siege, eine Niederlage unter anderem und zusätzlich Pokalsieg gegen Illertissen. Michi, fangen wir mal bei dir an. Das war ein ziemlich überzeugender Auftritt der Magdeburger am Samstagabend und man möchte fast fragen, wo war das denn davor, die Spiele?
Ja, das habe ich mich auch gefragt und ich habe mir auch dann mich ertappt bei dem Gedanken, wenn Magdeburg jetzt noch gute Stürmer hat, dann wird es eng für einen anderen Verein, den ich eng begleite. Ich finde schon, dass man die Saison über das Fehlen von Martijn K deutlich gemerkt hat, ist ja klar, also der war allein aufgrund seiner Torgefährlichkeit schon wichtig, aber auch aufgrund seiner Vielzahl an Sprints, also ich habe teilweise letzte Saison Werte gesehen, die ich selten in der 2. Liga sehe, was er da so an Sprints anzieht und an Tiefenläufen. Und das hat man zum Beispiel auch im Spiel gegen Fürth, jetzt sieht man ja 18 gegen 17, da war das damals noch nicht, aber eben ein Spiel unter Abstiegskongruenden hat man das gesehen, da hätten sie vermutlich auch gewonnen, die Magdeburger, wenn sie einen guten Stürmer gehabt hätten, den hatten sie damals zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht, haben damals trotzdem vier Tore geschossen, aber man hat jetzt dann auch festgestellt, das waren vier Zehntel aller ihrer Tore bis zu diesem Spieltag. Und dass sie dann jetzt mit Mateusz Cukowski, ja Eva, ich musste ja auch an den Rolf, den guten Rolf Cukowski denken, also du warst nicht alleine mit diesen wunderbaren Gedanken, dass der in seinem zweiten Spiel jetzt gleich mal zwei Tore macht. Ich musste erst mal ein bisschen mich einlesen, ich kannte den Spieler vorher nicht, ich habe dann grau in meinem Hirn irgendwo mich erinnert, dass sie den geholt haben, als Kars dann ging, also zum Deadline Day, wurde im Sommer verpflichtet, mit einem Mittelfußbruch vom FCM, musste dann jetzt länger warten, bis dieser Mittelfußbruch ausgeheilt war und seine Reha vorbei war. Und ja, wenn natürlich dieser Stürmer, der ein gewisses Talent hat, hat auch schon UN-Nationalmannschaften in Polen gespielt, wenn der jetzt funktioniert, im Wissen darum, dass Magdeburg auch guten Fußball spielen kann, dass es oftmals eher daran gescheitert ist, Spiele auch trotz einer gewissen Überlegenheit zu gewinnen, dann ist das für den 1. FC Magdeburg ein sehr gutes, sehr guter Erkenntnis für die andere Mannschaft im Tabellenkeller eher weniger und das hat ja auch dann gezeigt, dass es da zum Sieg gereicht hat, weil er dann eben einfach zwei Stürmer getroffen hat, faktisch doppelt, aber vier Stürmer im 1. FC Magdeburg, ich glaube, da kann man sehr viel Positives mitnehmen aus diesem Spiel.
Anna, wie schaust du auf die Entwicklung beim 1. FCM, vielleicht auch seit der Entlassung von Markus Wiedler?
Also aus Brautschweiger Perspektive natürlich besorgt, auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite auf eine Art auch hoffnungsvoll, weil ich das Spiel gesehen habe, jetzt im Vorgriff auf die Sendung, auch komplett und konzentriert und ausschließlich, das Brautschweiger Lied, das ich eben schon angedeutet hatte, so ein bisschen wiedererkannt habe. Also Markus Wiedler hatte in der Pressekonferenz im Anschluss gesagt, der einzige Unterschied heute ist, dass wir gewonnen haben. Im Spiel gab es eigentlich gar nicht so große Unterschiede. Und ich finde es wirklich verblüffend, weil der 1. FCM den zweitbesten Wert in puncto Torschüsse hat nach Elbersberg mit 207, aber nur 10 Tore daraus gemacht, hat vor dem Spiel. Also jetzt mehr Torschüsse und drei Tore mehr. Aber offenbar, ja, also ich fand es wirklich bemerkenswert und irgendwie schön bei allen Daten und Erklärweisen und Argumenten, die der Fußball so anzieht, dass man da dann eben einen Trainer auf die Frage, woran liegt es denn, Antworten hört, ja, wir treffen einfach das Tor nicht und vielleicht ist Fußball tatsächlich auch so einfach, vielleicht auch nicht, aber irgendwie fand ich, hat man der Mannschaft das gerade am Anfang auch angemerkt und ich finde es, ich hoffe, dass ich damit richtig liege, weil ich das bei der Braunschweiger Eintracht ähnlich meine beobachten zu können. Dass die Mannschaft sich von den schlechten Ergebnissen zuletzt oder von diesem Wankelmut oder zwischen dem Kontrast zwischen Ergebnis und Leistung nicht ins Bockshorn jagen lässt, sondern da fand ich wirklich von Beginn an sehr präsent gewesen ist und sehr überzeugend war.
Machst du den Witz oder so?
Nein, ich habe mir den Witz verkniffen.
Welchen Witz?
Mit Bockhorn und Bockshorn.
Oh, okay.
Low hanging fruit. Ja, ich fand es, also gerade ja auch in diesem Spiel relativ viele Torschüsse wieder, bzw. Schüsse, 19, davon 8 aus Tor, aber man hat es halt diesmal genutzt, also ein XG-Wert von 3,26. Da war schon viel Gutes dabei dieses Mal und ich glaube auch, dass diesmal gut geklappt hat. Die hilft halt auch der beste Stürmer vorne nichts, wenn du halt keine Spieler hast, die dir da irgendwie mal Tore vorbereiten und da muss ich einfach sagen…
Ich dachte, wir wollten noch gar nicht über Fürth reden jetzt.
Wow, das wird eine fantastische Folge. Du brauchst auch Spieler, so zurück zu meinem Faden, der irgendwie kurz dahinten hingegangen ist. Das hat geknackt, schön. Mit Neuenberger hatte man jemanden auf dem Rasen, der für mich, also abseits, klar, du hast Doppelpacker Zukowski, du hast einen Bräunig, der reinkommt und sein Tor oder seine Tore macht, in Anführungszeichen, aber Neuenberger war für mich der beste Magdeburger auf dem Platz. Also was der da über diese ganze Spiellänge abgeliefert hat, also eine 75-prozentige Passgenauigkeit, alleine X-Assist-Wert von 1,374 herausgespielte Chancen, also der war wirklich der Spieler, den Magdeburg eben auch brauchte. Und das fand ich schon, also ich dachte, ich meine, wir sprechen gleich auch noch über Nürnberg, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Ich meine, da gehören auch immer zwei zu, aber ich muss sagen, ich meine, wir hatten Thomas Haufe hier auch immer wieder sitzen, der gesagt hat, ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es ganz alleine an Markus Fiedler liegt, weil irgendwie die Probleme, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die mannschaftlich sind und eben nicht taktisch. Michi, ich würde dann die Frage mal an dich zurückspielen. Hast du denn schon das Gefühl, wie viel, ich stelle jetzt so eine richtig tolle Feier, wie viel Patrick Sander steckt in diesem Sieg?
Ich finde, dass es ein Sieg steckt, vor allem viel, als der FC Magdeburg, weil es ihnen in den letzten Jahren immer ausgezeigen hat, dass sie einfach sich nicht haben verrückt machen lassen. Also klar ist, sie haben Markus Fiedler entlassen, das konnte man nach den Ergebnissen vielleicht auch trotzdem verstehen. Manche hat sich vielleicht gewünscht, dass man ihnen mehr Zeit gibt. Die Rolle als Titznachfolger war natürlich auch sehr groß und die Fußstapfen waren noch größer. Aber dass man sich einfach treu bleibt, dass man auch seine Idee von Fußball treu bleibt, dass man auch im Abstiegskampf jetzt nicht auf Kratzen beißen, Rennen und lange Bälle setzt, sondern auf schönen Fußball, das imponiert mir, das gefällt mir auch sehr gut. Deswegen gönne ich ihnen auch den Erfolg, den sie haben. Ob es jetzt so viel Patrick Sander ist, ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich dann, vielleicht sogar mehr Othmar Schorck oder wer auch immer für die Strategie beim 1.Liga zu Magdeburg verantwortlich ist. Aber das nötigt mir schon einigen Respekt ab, weil das viele andere Vereine eben nicht tun, im Tabellenkiller sich einfach selbst treu zu bleiben. Und dass das dann mit Erfolgen bezahlt wird, ist doch umso schöner.
Ja, da will ich mitgehen. Ich bin halt generell, muss man natürlich immer aufpassen, ob es jetzt irgendwie so ein Ausrutscher nach oben war. Aber man muss ja einfach wirklich sagen, ihr habt es jetzt auch beide schon angesprochen. Eigentlich ging ja, wie man die Spiele verloren hat, weil dieses Düsseldorf-Spiel, ich glaube sowohl Düsseldorf als auch Magdeburg wussten nicht so ganz, warum das Spiel eigentlich so ausgeht. Und man muss ja einfach sagen, die Formkurve rein auf dem Platz hat ja schon in die richtige Richtung gezeigt. Und eigentlich kommt jetzt das Folgerichtige. Also du siehst eben diesen Schritt nach vorne, das, was andere Teams vielleicht unten drin noch nicht so haben. Und ich glaube, von daher ist das ein sehr, sehr gutes Zeichen für den 1. FCM. Und gerade in dieser Woche auch ein gutes Zeichen. Man spielt jetzt auswärts im Pokal gegen Rhabar Leipzig. Und ich schmeiße hier mein eigenes Phrasenschein an. Wann endlich verpflichtend Heimvorteil für unterklassige Teams. Also gerade das Spiel hätte ich no disrespect gegen Leipzig, aber tausendmal lieber in Magdeburg gesehen, als in Leipzig. Das ist einfach so. Und dann auswärts bei der Hertha. Also zwei durchaus ansprechende Auswärtsspieler für die Magdeburger Fans. Und da bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt, was wir da sehen. Weil gerade das Hertha-Spiel bin ich… Boah, mal schauen. Ich glaube, gerade mit der Qualität, die sie auch zeigen können, wenn ein barischer Artik auch… Ich habe so das Gefühl, der hat auch so langsam aber sicher wieder Spaß am Fußballspielen in dieser Mannschaft. Ich glaube, der ist halt auch jemand, der braucht Leute um sich herum, wo er weiß, auf die kann er sich auch irgendwie verlassen. Und die haben genauso Bock, für Magdeburg zu spielen, wie er auch. Und ich glaube, das war bei ihm jetzt auch so der Fall. Und von daher bin ich mal gespannt, was wir da von Magdeburg sehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr da sonst… Ich kann ja mal sagen, unser Ziel war so, dass wir mal so ein bisschen flotter. Aber damit will ich keine Leute abwürgen. Aber falls ihr euch sonst wundert, warum es vielleicht so ein bisschen kürzer ist als sonst. Wir haben ja auch viele schon besprochen. Aber Anna, ich wollte dir da sonst keine Punkte wegnehmen, wenn du da gerne noch was zum FCM sagen möchtest.
Nein, ich würde tatsächlich… Was heißt gerne? Aber doch, ich würde gerne über Nürnberg sprechen. Und zwar hatten die jetzt irgendwie eine ganz gute Strecke. 3 Siege in Folge, davor 2 Unentschieden, davor 1 Sieg. Und ich finde, dass in dieser schnelllebigen Berichterstattung klingt es dann schnell so, als Nürnberg, das ist so toll, was die alles machen, und so junge Spieler und so erfolgreich, trotz des jungen Kaders und so weiter und so fort. So klang es zumindest ein wenig im Fernsehkommentar am Samstag. Und ich habe so gedacht, ja, aber stand nicht Herr Klose schon zur Debatte im Endspiel gegen Düsseldorf? Und dann ist doch Daniel Thun gegangen. Aber wenn Daniel Thun das Spiel gewonnen hätte, dann wäre doch sehr wahrscheinlich Miro Klose gegangen, den zuvor gegangenen Berichterstattung zufolge. Und ich finde es einfach krass, wie schnell das irgendwie vergessen wird, dass der Saisonstart von Nürnberg wirklich nicht gut gewesen ist. Und haben wir dann im Anschluss die Pressekonferenz angehört und fanden es sehr interessant, dass Klose sagt, sie möchten jetzt den Turnaround schaffen nach dem Spiel, das er wohl als sehr negativ bewertet. Und das stößt ein bisschen in die Kerbe, die bei mir schon länger da ist, wenn ich das zugeben darf. Nämlich die Kerbe der Frage, ist Nürnberg das gute Pferd, das immer nur so hochspringt, wie es muss? Und das möchte ich gerne mal euch fragen, wie ihr das seht.
Darf ich, Eva? Ich bin ja sehr nah dran am 1. FC Nürnberg, sowohl geografisch als auch beruflich. Insofern kriege ich da sehr vieles mit von den Kollegen. Und es ist ein größeres Thema in Nürnberg, ob der Vertrag mit Miroslav Klose verlängert wird, der am Ende der Saison ausläuft. Und Joti Hatzi Alexiu, ich hoffe, ich habe ihn perfekt ausgesprochen, wie mein Kollege immer Wert drauflegt.
Glaube ja.
Also bei der Bild ist er immer der Club-Schatzi, aber ich glaube, er heißt Hatzi Alexiu. Er zögert noch sehr und er sagt, man wird jetzt erst mal diese Spiele spielen und dann mal schauen im Winter und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass es da schon mit reinspielt. Da waren zwei Ziege dabei, aber dann ist er wieder so ein, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Totalausfall ist, auf das andere Spiel kommen wir noch. Aber dem einen Mann, der einen Totalausfall hatte, aber 0 zu 3 beim Tabellenletzten ist schon für den 1. FC Nürnberg ein Brett und dass Miroslav Klose es halt offenbar nicht schafft, das dauerhaft gut hinzukriegen. Das hat auch Spieler sich da extrem schwer tun immer noch. Man hat im Sommer gefühlt 35 Stürmer verpflichtet und dann spielt der 8. Rafael Lubach die ganze Zeit im Sturm, weil keiner von den Stürmern irgendwie funktioniert. Das ist auch so ein Thema, er kriegt es auch nicht hin, die Stürmer in die Spur zu kriegen, obwohl er ja eigentlich, wir wissen alle, ein sehr guter Stürmer mal war und letzte Saison ja auch mit Emreli und, Gott ist mir der Name im Verein gefallen, der Stürmer beim 1. FC Nürnberg. Mein Kopf ist durch nach diesem langen Arbeitstag. Nein, das war der andere Stürmer, der zu Brighton gewechselt ist.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Oh Gott, ja, ich stehe auch komplett…
Aha. Aha, ja.
Wir sprechen erst weiter.
Wir werden darauf kommen auf den Namen. Ich habe ihn schon erfolgreich verdrängt, nachdem er im Viertelrundhof die Eckfahne geboxt hat nach seinem Tor. Er war auch in Grieche. Ich habe völlig den Pfaden verloren jetzt.
Aber jemals war es ja auch nicht, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Das ist jetzt extrem peinlich, dass ich hier jede Woche und gefühlt ein paar Kilometer von Nürnberg entfernt.
Meinst du, Kars Bayanda?
Nein, natürlich auch nicht.
Er ist auch kein Stürmer. Es ist ja wirklich hochgradig peinlich gerade.
Ja, wir könnten einfach schneiden an der Stelle. Jetzt höre ich Stefanos Ziemers natürlich.
Ja, klar.
Entschuldigt bitte, wir kommen gleich noch drauf, warum mein Kopf vielleicht heute etwas kaputt ist. Aber er war letztes Jahr auch gut, ist dann nach Brighton gewechselt. Also und war einer der Gründe, warum der 1. FCN Nürnberg einen Rekordumsatz gemacht hat. Aber das kriegt Klose eben auch nicht hin, deren Nachfolger in die Spur zu kriegen. Also man hat ja unter anderem Simen Tilalovic verpflichtet vom SSV Ulm, der hat noch gar keinen Tor gemacht und hat es teilweise gar nicht in Kader geschafft. Adriano Grimaldi von Paderborn hat man verpflichtet, hat ein sehr wichtiges gemacht, damit sie gewonnen haben. Aber jetzt auch nicht wirklich viel gespielt seitdem. Der beste Stürmer ist fast noch Mor mit Ali Soma. Ein Datentransfer aus der 3. italienischen Liga mit zwei Toren und auch sehr viel Dynamik vorne. Der FCN Nürnberg hat ja eine Kooperation mit Jamestown Analytics, weshalb man mehr Datentransfers macht. Aber der beste Stürmer ist Raphael Lubach, wie ich vorhin schon sagte. Und der ist eigentlich gar kein Stürmer, hat aber ganz viel als Stürmer da vorne gespielt. Man probiert auch sehr viel rum und hat ja jetzt im Spiel in Magdeburg gesehen, dass beim ersten Team Nürnberg ja doch noch viel zu einer Spitzenmannschaft fehlt, auch wenn man mal drei Spiele in der 2. Liga gewinnt. Also man kann da tabellarisch schon klettern, aber wie Anna richtig sagte, es gehört halt mehr dazu. Und in dieser 2. Liga muss man halt dann auch mal Spiele, also viele Spiele gewinnen, muss viel überzeugend spielen, muss auch defensiv gut stehen und eine 3 Tore gegen eine Mannschaft kassieren, die zuvor 10 nur geschossen hat. Und vor allem, was man in diesem Spiel jetzt gesehen hat, ist das Ader Mark hier auf dem Nürnberger Spiel. Aber sowas fehlt, wenn er nicht mitspielt, der 6er Strukturgeber und noch vieles mehr. Das konnte einfach niemand auffangen in diesem Spiel. Ich glaube, in Nürnberg werden sie alle beten, sofern sie gläubig sind, ich merke schon meinen Kopf, sofern sie gläubig sind, werden sie alle beten, dass er im Derby gegen die Spielvereinigung am Sonntag spielen kann, weil auch Rafael Lubach noch gelber Brot gesehen hat in Magdeburg. Das haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Also der beste Stürmer und der Mann, der vielleicht auch auf der Sechs hätte spielen können, fehlt im Derby. Und noch dazu kommt dann ein Trainerwechsel bei der anderen Mannschaft im Derby. Also die Vorzeigen sind nicht gut. Und dann lass uns einfach nur darüber reden, was passiert, wenn der Klub jetzt noch mal das Derby verlieren sollte. Dann ist vielleicht Nürnbergs Los, Vertragsverlängerung. Ja, ich würde mich schon freuen, wenn die Fürth dazu mit dem 0-4-0-3 verlieren. Das ist schon mal alles in Ordnung. Aber natürlich, deswegen wird man da auch zögern. Also man könnte ja ohne Probleme sagen, Miroslav Klose ist unser Trainer. Der hat viele junge Spieler entwickelt. Der hat eine riesige Strahlkraft, trotz teilweise schlechter Punkteausbeute und auch schlechter Spiele, trotz einem schlechten Saisonstart. Ich glaube, viele andere Trainer werden schon entlassen worden in Nürnberg, wenn sie nicht Miroslav Klose wären. Und insofern, ich kann es nachvollziehen, dass man da zögert als erster FC Nürnberg. Miroslav Klose würde es dann auch zeigen wollen und müssen, dass das keine Eintagsfliege war oder eine Dreitagsfliege mit diesen Siegen. Und es wird ja auch nicht einfacher. Ich bin auch noch gegen den FC Schalke, über den wir schon gesprochen haben, dass der dann doch relativ gut ist.
Ja, also Anna, ich würde auch sagen, ich habe Nürnberg letzte Woche live gesehen, auch wenn ich da vor allem gefroren habe im Max-Morlock-Stadion. Weil Bielefeld da halt gespielt hat. Und ja, ich meine, das 2-0 geht am Ende klar, 1-0 fährt aber auch nur durch einen Elfmeter. Und man hat es irgendwie so geschafft, 60 Minuten Bielefeld komplett vom eigenen Tor wegzuhalten. Und dann gab es aber am Ende, hat Bielefeld am Ende 16 zu 11 Schüsse gehabt. Okay, davon nur einen Schuss auf Tor. Aber trotzdem, man sieht ja schon, dass es da auch Defensivprobleme gibt. Da wurden sie halt nicht so komplett auf die Probe gestellt gegen Bielefeld. Aber gegen Magdeburg fand ich das schon auch sehr befremdlich, wie einfach es da zum Teil ging und mit welchen einfachen Mitteln man da zum Teil die letzte Kette auch überspielen konnte. Und man eigentlich immer in die gleichen Fallen der Magdeburger auch gelaufen sind. Und was die können, ist auch gerade mit einem Artik oder so, ist jetzt auch nichts Neues. Dass sie auch durchaus was mit dem Ball anfangen können, ist nichts Neues. Und das fand ich schon auch erschreckend am Samstagabend. Und Michi, du hast es gesagt, mit Lubach, also er verschuldet ja erst den Freistoß zum 1-0. Und fliegt dann eben mit gelb-rot ins Beimer, weil er eben ja in diese Defensivrolle schlüpfen muss. Und da jeweils eben Magdeburger Angriff unterbindet. Und da im Timing komplett zu spät kommt, dass ich glaube über die gelb-rote Karte muss man überhaupt nicht diskutieren auch. Und das ist ja, also du siehst auch irgendwie Zepanow vorne, der einfach komplett irgendwie in der Luft hängt. Ja, möchtest du das sagen mit der ukrainischen Haarland oder lassen wir das? Du bist auch stumm, du bist auch stumm.
Ihr merkt schon, dieser Verein rafft mich dahin, über den ich immer berichten muss. Nein, ich möchte nicht über ukrainischen Haarland sprechen, weil ich den Namen so oft gehört habe in den letzten Monaten. Und man in jedem Spiel sieht, dass da noch sehr, sehr viel fehlt zu einem gewissen Erling Haarland und auch das. Also ich habe ihn vergessen zu erwähnen vorhin, weil er die anderen Stürmer haben schon alles überstrahlt im Negativen. Aber er spielt ja immer noch relativ viel. Er war zwischenzeitlich auch mal raus und hat dann gar nicht gespielt. Jetzt spielt er wieder immer. Aber klar, die meisten Spieler hat trotzdem Lubach als Stürmer gemacht. Im Derby wird er das auf jeden Fall nicht machen. Deswegen wird er vermutlich wieder spielen.
Ich hatte im Vorhinein auch das Gefühl, wenn man das Spiel gewinnt, dann könnte man nach der Winterpause ein bisschen gucken, in welche Richtung diese Saison noch gehen könnte. Und dann kommt der 1. FCN direkt mit, ja, nee. Man ist gerade wirklich Platz 10, 18 Punkte, 15 zu 19 Tore, 5 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, 6 Niederlagen. Man ist auch in der Formtabelle auf Platz 10. Das ist alles irgendwie so Mittelmaß. Und deshalb gehe ich eben auch damit, dass ich das ehrlich gesagt gut verstehen kann, dass man eben noch nicht mit Klose verlängert. Also wir haben auf der einen Seite, wenn man so ein bisschen die Diskussion rund um Nico Kovac beim BVB mitbekommen hat, als da der Vertrag verlängert wurde, dann finde ich es gleichzeitig etwas vermessend, dann bei Nürnberg zu sagen, ja klar, warum haben sie es noch nicht gemacht? Man muss ja auch immer sagen, da hängt ja finanziell auch was dahinter. Und wir wissen auch, da lief es auch nicht immer super für Nürnberg. Also, um sich da irgendwie noch die Baustelle aufzumachen, drei Jahre im Endeffekt einen Trainer zu bezahlen, den man dann eventuell schon nächstes Frühjahr dann doch entlässt, das sollte man vielleicht auch besser lassen. Und da sage ich auch ganz ehrlich, bin ich dann auch auf Schatzi Alexou Seite, dass man sich da eben die Zeit lässt. Und ich hätte mir witzigerweise auch einfach als Stichpunkt, also Anna, als hättest du meine Notizen gelesen, ich hab mir so schön aufgeschrieben, einfach nur Quo Vades, FCN, weil es ist irgendwie, ja, es ist halt Mittelmaß der 2. Liga. Also das ist für andere Vereine sicherlich ein Kompliment, für den FCN meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Man hat ja auch andere Ziele. Also hat der Schatzi Alexou auch ausgegeben, dass man zu den Top 25 gehören will in Deutschland. 18 plus 7, mehr 25, da ist man als Zehntel bisschen weg. Und wenn man jetzt sieht, wie gut andere Mannschaften trotzdem spielen können, die da weiter oben stehen, dann ist die Ceiling vom FCN eine andere. Und da fehlt schon noch einiges. Und wie gesagt, man ist von einem Spieler vor allem sehr abhängig, von Mark Hef auf der 6 zum Beispiel. Klar, da ist viel da. Man hat auch wirklich gute Jugendarbeit. Da könnten wir jetzt sehr lange einen Schwerpunkt zum FCN machen, dass man– ja, man hat ja schon viele Spieler verkauft, du hast vorhin Usun gesagt– man hat auch Nathaniel Brown, vergisst man gerne, der quitt im Dunstkreis der Nationalmannschaft schon. Das kommt vom 1. FC Nürnberg, von Jelcz. Also es gibt ja so viele Spieler, die von da kommen und es kommen schon die nächsten gefühlt nach von unten. Die U19 und U17 vom 1. FC Nürnberg sind gut, spielen in diesen DFB-Nachwuchsliegen eine gute Rolle. Da kommen Talente nach. Die 2. Mannschaft ist 1. FC Nürnberg. Große Freude bei allen Drittligisten ist derzeit Erster in der Regionalliga Bayern und es wird geprüft, ob man aufsteigen will oder ob man den Antrag zum Aufstieg stellt. Das heißt, es könnte eine 2. Mannschaft in die 3. Liga hochkommen. Das spricht aber auch dafür, dass da eben auch viele Talente dahinter sind. Auch wenn man natürlich da jetzt sagen muss, dass da viele Talente spielen, die beim 1. FC Nürnberg für die 1. Mannschaft eingeplant waren. Also unter anderem Justin Vonderhitz, den man aus Köln kennt und auch in den DFB-Nachwuchs, die ihm schon gut war, oder Ayub Çayko, der hat auch schon in der 2. Liga gespielt. Die spielen alle in der 2. Mannschaft momentan, weshalb die halt da die Regionalliga Bayern gerade rasiert. Aber man ist auf jeden Fall jetzt auch Wintermeister in der Regionalliga Bayern. Also da läuft schon im Hintergrund vieles gut und irgendwie scheint der Fundus an Talenten irgendwie unerschöpflich. Das ist schon auch bewundernswert.
Ich fand eine Sache auch bewundernswert. Und zwar, ich habe eben schon mal am Anfang gesagt, es gab eben überall eigentlich wieder diese 12-Minuten-Protest in den Stadien. Bei Magdeburg gegen Nürnberg war es nochmal speziell. Da waren die beiden Ultra-Gruppierungen, also sowohl aus Nürnberg als auch von Magdeburg, die ersten 12 Minuten gar nicht auf den Tribünen, sondern sind dann erst gekommen. Support startete dann erst mit der 30. Minute. Da muss ich echt sagen, Respekt vor allem an die Nürnberg-Fans, also die Strecke auf sich zu nehmen für den Samstagabend, dann die ersten 12 Minuten draußen zu bleiben und dann erst in der 30. Minute mit Support zu starten und dann noch 0 zu 3 verlieren. Also gab es sicherlich schönere Samstagabende, aber zeigt da glaube ich auch nochmal, dass es eben durchaus wichtigere Dinge gibt, als nur das Ergebnis nach 90 Minuten oder in dem Fall 110 Minuten. Das fände ich, mögen andere Leute nicht verstehen können. Ich finde es sehr bemerkenswert tatsächlich.
Die sind ja leidgeprüft, die Fans des ESNF zu Nürnberg. Insofern können sie das vermutlich leichter ab, als manch anderer 2. Liga-Fan. Aber klar, unterstützenswert, ich würde nur unterstreichen, was du gesagt hast. Die Proteste gegen die Pläne der Innenministerkonferenz waren gut. Sie waren auch in allen Stadien gut und wichtig. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Joachim Herrmann, einem Innenminister zugehört hat, der schon heftig zurückgerodert, dann waren sie vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt falsch und haben zum Ziel geführt. Wir werden alles sehen, wohin es dann am Ende führt. Aber da verzichtet man gerne mal 30 Minuten lang auf Unterstützung, wenn man dafür nicht künftig mit einem KI-Gesichtsgänger ins Stadion gehen muss. Ich habe da keine Lust drauf.
Wobei man, finde ich, da auch ergänzend zu sagen kann, dass diese Proteste in den Kurven durchaus erstaunlich sinnvoll ergänzt werden durch die Live-Kommentare. Das hat mich durchaus nicht überrascht, um mir an der Stelle eine doppelte Verneinung zu gönnen. Weil natürlich sind da Leute dabei wie Thorsten Matuszka, die ich mit der Bengalo einschlafen sehe. Andere aber weniger.
Oh Gott, Kopfkino.
Aber das fand ich irgendwie cool, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, dass es da Personen gab, die sehr bewusst den Impuls in Richtung Fernsehpublikum gesetzt haben, dass man doch bitte nicht von den Chaoten sprechen soll, die alle irgendwie am Bahnhof festgehalten werden, sondern diejenigen, die auch die Fernsehübertragung einfach stimmungsvoll und wichtig machen. Ich finde halt die ersten 12 Minuten ist wie Snooker einfach. Weil die Leute auch anders anfangen zu reden. So dieses Ja, da schießt der Torhüter den Ball über die Mittellinie.
Schön.
Das möchte ich nicht.
Michi, du wolltest etwas ergänzen.
Ich habe das auch sehr positiv wahrgenommen. Und das war auch schon mal anders. Und ich glaube, das ist schon auch ein Verdienst einer breiteren Öffentlichkeitsarbeit von den Fanszenen. Also man könnte es jetzt Professionalisierung von Fanszenen nennen. Aber ich kriege es ja auch mit. Es gibt an allen Standorten mittlerweile diese Fanhilfen, die sehr gute Arbeit machen. Diese deutschlandweite Bündnis funktioniert sehr gut. Es gab ja vor einigen Wochen auch diese zwei Wochen diese Demo in Leipzig. Und da waren ja auch sehr viele 2. Liga-Fanszenen zum Beispiel da. Also die Vernetzung der deutschen Fankultur ist, oder Fanszenen, Ultraszenen, aktiven Fanszenen, wie man immer man das nennen mag, ist schon sehr gut. Und ich glaube, die Kommentatoren springen da auch gerne darauf an, wenn man ihnen natürlich praktische Handreichungen gibt. Aber ich fand das auch überraschend. Das war, glaube ich, sogar beim Topspiel am Samstagabend, dass der Kommentator da meinte auf Sky, ja, also das hat mit den Bürgerrechten ja gar nichts zu tun. Also auch in einer Vehemenz, das zu betonen, die für Sky eigentlich schon ungewohnt ist. Also das zeigt natürlich dann auch, wie schlimm diese Pläne sind, was da drohen könnte. Dann bekommen wir auch noch gleich auch Fürth gegen Bochum. Da haben die Geschäftsführer beider Vereine mit den Ultras beider Vereine gemeinsam vor dem Spiel protestiert. Kommt jetzt auch nicht alltäglich vor, dass Ultras und Geschäftsführer einträchtig gegen die Pläne von Innenministern demonstrieren. Also das zeigt schon, dass da halt Dinge im Raum stehen, die auch Vereine für gefährlich halten. Und dann schließt man sich dem vielleicht auch leichter an. Aber ich würde da nichts unterstellen. Ich glaube, dass die Menschen dort auch das verstanden haben und mittlerweile vielleicht auch mehr ein Auge und ein Gespür für Fan-Kultur haben. Das ist ja auch eine schöne Erkenntnis.
Ja, also gerade Samstagabend war es Hansi Küpper. Der ist da in letzter Zeit schon öfter aufgefallen. Der hat ja auch den Podcast mit seinen beiden Söhnen und seiner Tochter, glaube ich. Und Corny Küpper ja unter anderem auch Kommentator bei Sky. Die haben ja ganz häufig in der Bundesliga dann dieses Freitagabend-Doppelspiel. Und da muss ich sagen, was mir an Hansi Küpper vor allem so gut gefällt, ist, dass er tatsächlich, also er wirkt informiert. Also da kommen dann nicht irgendwie die Standard-Zweisätze, sondern er füttert das auch wirklich mit Infos, sodass eben auch die ZuschauerInnen vom Fernseher wissen, worum es geht. Und er hat, glaube ich, eben gesagt, also es wird die Rechtsstaatlichkeit, wird quasi ausgesetzt, gerade bei diesem Konzept Stadionverbot aus der Gießkanne. Also dass eben ohne Ermittlungsverfahren du auf Verdacht ein dreimonatiges Stadionverbot bekommst. Und da, die haben auch rund um die Demo echt gut berichtet. Also da möchte ich eben unterstreichen, es ist super wichtig, dass das außerhalb der Stadion passiert, ob das in Zeitungsberichten ist. Also wenn selbst hier die lokale Presse darüber schreibt, dann weißt du auch, ui, das scheint da auch angekommen zu sein. Gut, ich meine, ich muss da einfach sagen, dadurch, dass ich für Freunde arbeite, weiß ich auch, dass das Thema da immer eng ist. Aber das ist eben auch super wichtig. Und ich glaube, das sehen viele Fans eben auch so, dass man es da gut schaffen kann, eine Beziehung zur Presse oder zur breiteren Öffentlichkeit aufzustellen. Also in Bielefeld wurden gestern an jedem Sitz auch noch mal Zettel verteilt mit dem Hinweis auf zur Petition. Und es haben sich auf jeden Fall auch in Bielefeld– also ich meine, das war auch ein Derby– das ist ein Spiel, da tut es einem auch irgendwie weh, die ersten 12 Minuten vielleicht zu schweigen, weil das halt so ein wichtiges, also eins der wichtigsten Spiele der Saison, ehrlich gesagt, ist und das zeigt es eben auch noch mal, wie weit das geht. Es war ein kleiner Exkurs, aber ich hatte auch das Gefühl, es war uns allen noch mal wichtig und wir meckern hier auch an anderer Stelle viel. Aber ich glaube, das war wirklich, also ist momentan ein Lob wert, vor allem, wenn ich dann gleichzeitig sehe– ich habe einen FAZ-Artikel heute gelesen, wo der Autor anscheinend leider nicht die Fähigkeit hat, Spruchbänder richtig zu lesen und zu interpretieren. Das ist dann gleichzeitig vielleicht auch nicht so gut.
Ganz kurz noch zum Thema Derby eingehakt. Das war ja bei dem Derby Braunschweig Hannover Thema Teilzuschauer-Ausschluss in der vergangenen Saison. Und unterm Strich stehen einfach höhere Polizeikosten, weil du die Leute halt nicht im Stadion hast. Also grundsätzlich musst du halt einfach auch nur eine größere von einer kleineren Zahl unterscheiden können, wenn es um Personalaufwand, Kosten und so weiter und so fort. Also, naja, egal.
Ich habe noch einen kurzen Einwand dazu.
Bitte.
Ich bin bekennender Freund, habe ich glaube ich auch ausgehört, von Fankultur und auch bekennender Freund von Pyrotechnik. Aber natürlich ist es trotzdem kontraproduktiv, wenn dein Fußballspiel 20 Minuten unterbrochen wird nach diesen Protesten aufgrund von Pyrotechnik.
Zweiteinhalb.
Ja, gefühlt 20 für mich. Vor dem Fernseher war es sehr lange. Und hat das wahrscheinlich schon auch ein bisschen mit der Witterung zu tun. Ich bin jetzt kein Meteorologe, aber in Darmstadt war es vergangene Woche ja auch so, dass nach den Pyroaktionen der Darmstädter sehr lange unterbrochen war, weil das in der feuchten Luft offenbar länger hingen. Und das war ja tatsächlich so, dass man in Magdeburg, mein Kollege auch gesagt, Fadike Blavik, Grüße an der Stelle, der hier auch schon mal zu Gast war, dass man wirklich gar nichts mehr gesehen hat. Also man hat wirklich nichts mehr gesehen im Stadion. Und das führt die Proteste natürlich wieder nicht an Absurdum, aber hat so einen Faden Beigeschmack, weil man dann halt irgendwie dann sagt, es gibt mit Sicherheit Menschen, die etwas kürzer denken und nicht zu viel nachdenken und sagen, ist doch alles richtig, wenn die so kacke bauen im Stadion. Ich habe mal auch schon wahrgenommen, dass dann viele Fans trotzdem zeigen wollten, dass auch Biotechnik für sie dazugehört, zu diesem Stadionerlebnis. Aber ich glaube, keiner will, dass ein Fußballspiel 15 oder 12 oder 20 oder wie auch immer unterbrochen wird, weil am Ende sind wir ja trotzdem im Stadion wegen des Fußballspiels.
Ich sage ganz stumpf, ich nehme trotzdem lieber die 12 Minuten für Pyro als für VR. Das ist dann vielleicht meine persönliche Meinung. Aber trotzdem muss man da einmal noch kurz zur Differenzierung. Bei der Pyrotechnik geht es ja den Leuten vor allem nicht darum, dass die Sicht eingeschränkt ist, sondern dass es gefährlich ist. Ich sage mal so, ich bin Asthmatikerin und wenn 90 Minuten jemand neben mir mit Kippe steht, finde ich das so einiges anstrengender. Aber gut, das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Diskussion. Das ist natürlich auch sehr subjektives Empfinden. Aber ich glaube, so oder so– also ich habe es heute Morgen in der Bundesliga der Männer-Sendung schon gesagt– es ist schon sehr interessant, was da jetzt aus Richtung der Innenminister kommt, was zum Teil aus Richtung der Polizei kommt. Da hat man so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es wird etwas geschwommen. Ist dann ja gut, dass man die Weser nahe hat am Wochenende oder vom 3. bis zum 5. ist, die noch mal, wer da nicht Bescheid weiß, wird sicherlich auch an anderer Stelle noch darüber berichtet werden. Ich sag mal so, wir sind gespannt, was da kommt. Und womit könnte ich das nächste Spiel besser ankündigen als wir sind gespannt? Wir wollen nämlich sprechen über die Spielvereinigung für gegen den VfL Bochum. Es ist auch hier ein Sieg, allerdings nicht für die Heimmannschaft, sondern für die Gäste aus Bochum. Es war sehr schnell zu Ende. Das erste Gegentor, das ist nach einem Freistoß durch Sissouko, das zweite Gegentor nach Ecke auch durch Sissouko. Dann trifft Hoffmann noch mit dem dritten Torschuss zum dritten Tor. Am Ende führt das nach gefühlten 18 Minuten.
17 waren es.
17. Ich sage einmal ganz kurz, es ist Platz 17, es sind 13 Punkte, es sind 20 zu 37 Tore. Ich konnte die Hälfte meines Punktes zu Fürth hier endlich stehen lassen, weil es ist weiterhin die schlechteste Defensive der Liga. Man hat vier Siege, einen unentschieden und neun Niederlagen. Die Formtabelle in den letzten fünf Spielen, ohne große Überraschung, zeigt auch Platz 18 an. Und ich weiß, wir haben hier auch vor nicht so langer Zeit schon über Fürth geredet, aber als wir in die Fürtha uns ein Gefallen tun wollen, haben sie dann heute Abend Thomas Kleine entlassen. Wir haben ihn letztes Mal schon sehr lange aufgedröselt, wann er übernommen hat, wie gut die Entscheidung war, mit ihm in die neue Saison zu gehen, etc. Er hatte am Endeffekt ein Punktdurchschnitt von 1,00. Und weil ich hier nicht der Profi bin, wenn es um Fürth ging und der Experte Michi, was war denn jetzt ausschlaggebend für diese Entlassung?
Vor allem eine Zahl, würde ich mal sagen. 37. Also 37 Gegentore ist schon hart. Es wird ja auch auf Sky immer wieder erwähnt, dass der FSV Frankfurt vor vielen Jahren schlechter war. Und vor diesem Spieltag, ich habe die Zahl nicht nochmal aktualisiert, aber vor diesem Spieltag hatte es sogar Jan Regensburg, die vergangene Saison ja wirklich katastrophal teilweise verteidigt haben, die 0 zu 4 und 3 zu 8 verloren haben gegen Fürth und Nürnberg in der Abfolge. Die hatten sogar weniger Gegentore zum gleichen Zeitpunkt vor diesem Spieltag jetzt. Und das Krasse ist ja, dass Thomas Kleine eigentlich mal Inverteidiger war. Der war der Aufstiegskapitän der Fürther 2011-2012. Er hat einen Co-Trainer Miloš Radpiković, der hier ein beinharter zweikampfstarker Sechser war. Und sie haben das halt so überhaupt nicht hinbekommen, diese Defensive zu stabilisieren. Und es kommt auch überhaupt nicht überraschend, dass sie das nicht hinbekommen haben. Weil ich bin ja manchmal auch leider aber sehr nah dran als Reporter. Und ich habe es in der Vorbereitung schon gesehen, da hat man selbst gegen mittelmäßige Vierteligisten zwei Tore kassiert in mehreren Spielen. Man hat eigentlich immer gegen Tore kassiert, außer gegen Union Berlin bei der Generalprobe, was auch nicht unbedingt für Union sprach zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Und man hat dann ja auch in den ersten Spielen, also 3-2 gegen Dresden, 2-3 in Braunschweig, da wird sich Anna noch erinnern, dieses Spiel. Man hat fünf Tore bekommen in den ersten beiden Spielen. Am Ende waren es dann 11 vor der ersten Länderspielpause. Da und 3, ja 4 vom 1. FC Magdeburg. Ich habe vorhin gesagt, das waren 4 von 10, die Magdeburg bis vor diesem Spieltag geschossen hat. Also das zeigt schon ganz gut auf, wo die Probleme lagen. Man hat das auch nie in den Griff bekommen. Stattdessen gab es dann ja ein 0-6 in Elbersberg, ein 1-4 gegen Karlsruhe. Also wirklich katastrophale Ergebnisse. Dann hat man irgendwie so, eigentlich damals schon gedacht, das Kleine entlassen würde, also zumindest mal nach diesen beiden Spielen, also innerhalb von fünf Tagen 1-10 Tore zu bekommen, auch im Wissen darum, was davor passiert ist, dass schon mal ein Wutausbruch von Felix Klaus nach einem 0-1 auf Schalke gab, bei dem er sagte, schlechter als wir kann man nicht spielen. Das ist auch eine schöne Aussage von dem Fußballer. Also es gab ja ganz viele Indizien, die darauf hingedeutet haben, aber Stefan Fürstner hat sich energisch gewehrt, Thomas Kleine freizustellen. Kann man vielleicht auch damit erklären, dass er jetzt der dritte Trainer schon war von Stefan Fürstner als Sportdirektor. Also wir erinnern uns, es gab Leo Haas, es gab einen gewissen Jan Siebert und dann gab es Thomas Kleine und dann glaube ich schon als erster Sportdirektor, als Sportdirektor in seiner ersten Amtszeit, wird man jetzt nicht gleich den vierten Trainer unbedingt holen wollen, aber er musste jetzt dann doch machen nach diesem 0-3 gegen Bochum, vergangene Woche ja ein 2-4 auch in Darmstadt im Topspiel, also wieder sieben Gegentore in zwei Spielen und dieser Auftritt gegen Bochum. Er hat sogar Stefan Fürstner gesagt, dass er katastrophal war und dann blieb ihm keine andere Möglichkeit mehr, aber es hat trotzdem lange gedauert. Also man recherchiert dann ja als Journalist sehr viel. Ich habe heute Vormittag dann schon viel recherchiert und habe dann auch um 12 Uhr verkündet, dass Kleine und seine beiden Assistenten, also sowohl Milorad Bekovic als auch Marco Konrad beurlaubt sind, aber es hat dann bis 17.15 Uhr gedauert, bis der Verein das auch verkündet hat. Und bis der Verein verkündet hat, dass Heiko Vogel, der neue Trainer, der Spielvereinigung Eva Lacht, wird. Ja, es ist der Heiko Vogel, der den FC Basel 2011-12, glaube ich, zum Meistertitel geführt hat, zum Pokalsieg, der mit dem FC Basel mal den FC Bayern geschlagen hat. Aber ihr merkt, ich habe mich heute schon viel eingelesen in andere Themen. Deswegen verzeihten wir meinen kurzen Aussetzer bei Stefanos Zimas. Also er hat damals mit dem FC Basel den FC Bayern geschlagen, bei dem irgendwie Kroos, Ribéry, Robben und alles dabei waren. War das 8. Finale der Champions League damals. Das Rückspiel ging 7-0 für Bayern aus. Also da war es dann Schluss. Aber er ist dann später nochmal nach einer Zeit bei den Bayern Amateuren der 2. Mannschaft des FC Bayern ja auch mit Sturm Graz nochmal Pokalsieger geworden. Zuletzt aber dann doch eher beim Kfc Ördingen und bei Borussia Mönchengladbach 2 und Sportdirektor beim FC Basel. Und seit 2 Jahren ohne Job. Und jetzt zurück in der 2. Bundesliga.
Anna, einmal an dich die Frage, wie ist so deine Außenperspektive aufgeführt?
Also ich hatte die letzte Saison ja schon als stetigen Begleiter im Abstiegskampf. Auf dem Vizier, weil die genauso wie wir eben bis zum Ende tatsächlich geschwommen sind. Und uns hat, glaube ich, die beiden Vereine, Braunschweig und Fürth, ein, glaube ich, so ein bisschen dieses Nein, wir halten am Trainer fest. Und wir hatten uns da ja zwischenzeitlich auch in der Rasenfunk-Zweitliga-Allstar-Gruppe drüber ausgetauscht, was da wohl irgendwie für Motive hinterstecken. Ich fand es ganz spannend zu sehen, oder meine sehen zu können, dass es halt so Motive sind, die überall ähnlich sind. Dass du eine Entscheidung triffst, die bringt dich in wirtschaftliche Nöte oder Verpflichtungen. Also wie jetzt irgendwie in Fürth vor zwei Jahren dieser Entschluss, wir wollen sportlich einen Neuanfang wagen, Alexander Zorniger gehen lassen, etc.,
pp. Das war erst vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr? Oh Gott, okay.
13 Monate.
Und dann laufen da aber Verträge und dann verpflichtet man Trainer und dann funktioniert das nicht und dann muss man das teuer korrigieren. Und dass diese steigenden finanziellen Verpflichtungen dazu führen, dass du einfach viel weniger handlungsfähig bist in den Situationen, in denen du aber dringend handeln solltest oder zumindest, ja, die Freiheit haben solltest, zu sagen, irgendwie funktioniert das nicht. Ich glaube, wir müssen was machen und dann kannst du aber nicht, weil du einfach so viele Payrolls zu bedienen hast. Und ich nehme Fürth aus Fan-Perspektive so wahr, dass es also tatsächlich ein Verein ist, der mir Mut gibt, dass am Ende noch jemand hinter der Braunschweiger Eintracht steht. Und das meine ich gar nicht. Also ich habe nichts, ich muss hier kein böses Blut oder so entstehen lassen oder so. Da ist überhaupt nichts. Ich hatte mal einen sehr netten Besuch beim Frauenländerspiel in Fürth und mochte das da eigentlich immer gern, insofern gar nicht dispektierlich gemeint. Aber wenn wir heute über die einzelnen Spiele als Aufhänger sprechen wollen, das fand ich erschreckend tatsächlich, was ich da gesehen habe. Zumal Bochum ja in der Pressekonferenz noch angekündigt hat, dass sie sich auf Standards konzentrieren wollen, um das Spiel erfolgreich zu gestalten. Und dann setzen sie das genauso um und nach 18 Minuten, und das musst du dir im Abstiegskampf auch echt erst mal leisten können, weil Bochum jetzt nicht so viel glänzender im Trend schon, in der Tabelle noch nicht dasteht, den Betrieb im Prinzip völlig einzustellen. Und es passiert trotzdem nichts. Dann passieren keine Wechsel in der Halbzeit. Und der erste Torschuss ist irgendwie so Mitte sechzigste Minute. Das finde ich schon, also gerade auch, ich meine, wir haben vorhin schon über Magdeburg gesprochen, ein ähnliches Tabellensegment, komplett, komplett anderer Auftritt, komplett andere Außendarstellung, komplett andere Körpersprache. Insofern bin ich sehr gespannt, was da jetzt passiert, weil Stefan Fürstner jetzt in den Interviews nicht so wirkt, wie der strahlende Kapitän, der das sinkende Schiff jetzt aus dem Sturm rausnavigiert. Vielleicht täusche ich mich. Aber irgendwie, finde ich, lullt man sich da so ein bisschen ein, in so ein, das wird schon und wir zusammen. Aber, also kein gutes Gefühl. Mir macht da wenig, oder ich sehe da von außen wenig, was mir zur Anlass gibt, dir, Michael, jetzt zu sagen, ach, das wird schon. Keine Sorge.
Ich habe ja alle Spiele bislang gesehen, da gibt es für mich auch wenig Anlass zu sagen, das wird schon. Es gäbe viele Angriffungspunkte. Ich wollte nur eines sagen mit dem schlechtesten, also die Schmiefang ist gerade faktisch die schlechteste Mannschaft der 2. Liga. Und es gab ja auch vor der Saison sehr viele Tipps von selbsternannten Expertinnen und Experten, aber auch hier im All-Star-Team und so weiter haben ganz viele Menschen Fürth als Abstiegskandidaten getippt. Und das ist auch offenbar im Umfeld der Mannschaft angekommen. Felix Klaus hat in meinem Interview gesagt, das haben sie sich quasi selbst auch besprochen oder in die Kabine gehängt. Und sie wollen allen zeigen, dass es besser geht. Und sie haben es dann ja schon bestätigt gefühlt, weil sie ja an den ersten Spieltagen ja schon zwei von vier Spielen gewonnen haben. Sie waren dann gar nicht so schlecht. Sie haben Magdeburg und Dresden geschlagen. Sie haben viele Tore geschossen. Jetzt sieht man halt, dass dann doch die strukturellen Probleme extrem groß sind. Als wir über die Defensive gesprochen. Anna hat die drei Gegentore angesprochen. Also das war nicht zweitligatauglich, wie man da verteidigt hat. Also bei keinem Tor. Beim ersten sind da zwei Spieler, die einfach sich soko laufen lassen. Beim zweiten steht Dietz hinter ihm und die Soko muss nur seinen Fuß kurz ausschneiden, lassen wie so ein Tippkick-Männchen und trifft dann dadurch. Beim dritten spielt Münz, also Reno Münz, 20 Jahre jungen Innenverteidiger, der als links Fuß rechts in der Dreieckkette spielen musste, weil zwei andere rechts Fußinnenverteidiger verletzt sind, einen Chipball ins eigene Zentrum, 16 Meter vorm Tor. Also ganz komisch, Zier ist dann zu hüftsteif im Strafraum. Da könnte man jetzt viel über Kaderplanung reden. Philipp Zier soll dann neuer Abwehrchef werden, das ist er faktisch gerade noch nicht. Man hat mit Matthias Ohles einen Sechser geholt, der jetzt auch gegen Bochum nicht mitgespielt hat, weil er die Woche zuvor in Darmstadt eine Zweikampfquote von 0 Prozent hatte. Also muss man ausmarschieren, als Sechser 0 Prozent, acht verlorene Duelle in Darmstadt. Deswegen sind ja auch zwei von vier Toren aus dem berühmten Sechser-Raum gefallen vergangene Woche bei diesem Topspiel, weil da einfach kein Sechser war, ob man in diesem Raum hätte sein sollen. Also es gäbe so, so, so viele Ansatzpunkte und wirklich ist es extrem schwer, weil Anna jetzt schon das Finanzielle angesprochen hat. Es steht wirklich auch ganz schlecht in dem Spiel, vor allen Dingen, also man ist in einer sportlichen Krise, aber auch in einer finanziellen Krise und das als Verein, der ja schon immer für wirtschaftliche Solidität und für seriöses Wirtschaften stand. In der Länderspielpause war auch die Jahreshauptversammlung der Spielvereinigung zuvor auch die Bilanz-PK und man hat da, es spielt keine große Rolle in Deutschland, weil halt Fürth dann doch für vieles irrelevant ist, aber man hat halt 4,7 Millionen Miese gemacht im letzten Jahr. Davon sind 2 Millionen, also 1,9, knapp 2 Millionen sind Sondereffekte, nämlich Abfindungen für Zorniger und Asusi plus Sergio Pinto, den Chefscout, den man ja auch freigestellt hat, plus Jan Sievert war ja auch noch da, also und Jurek Rohrberg und vergiss den Assistent von Alexander Zorniger, der früher bei Sky gearbeitet hat, wenn wir vorhin schon Sky-Kompetatoren gelobt haben. Also diese Menschen hat man alle freigestellt, deswegen hat man 2 Millionen ausgeben müssen und hat dadurch auch keinerlei Transfererlöse bis auf 1,5 Millionen für Amindo Sieb, den man ja vielleicht auch noch kennt in der 2. Liga. Die hat man bewusst in dieses Geschäftsjahr schon reingeschoben und trotzdem hat man 4,7 Millionen Euro Miese gemacht. Natürlich auch bedingt durch das Fernsehgeld-Ranking, in dem man jedes Jahr weiter abgerutscht ist. Also Srivagnath, der Finanzgeschäftsführer, mittlerweile auch alleinige Geschäftsführer, hat gesagt, man ist jedes Jahr um zwei Plätze abgerutscht, von 4 auf 6 auf 8. Das macht natürlich immer einiges an Geld aus, nur wenn man jedes Jahr 13. bis 15. wird, wird es natürlich auch nicht besser. Dann klettert man es, sondern fällt eher noch mehr. Und diesen Verlust hat man aber nicht zu ausgewiesen, sondern man hat einen Bilanzverlust von 0,1 Millionen, also 100.000, nur ausgewiesen, weil man sein Eigenkapital halbiert hat. Und das ist ja auch kein gutes Zeichen, weil Fürth jetzt nur noch 2,5 Millionen Eigenkapital hatte. Man hatte mal 7,8 Millionen, also man war da ja auch extrem gut. Die Eigenkapitalquote ist bei knapp 25 Prozent nur noch, das ist auch so im Zweiten Jahr vielleicht gar nicht mal so gut, wie es mal war. Und wenn wir jetzt wissen, dass man jetzt schon den nächsten Trainer wieder bezahlen muss, plus ja auch zwei weitere Assistenten noch bezahlen muss und die anderen drei jetzt noch einen Vertrag bis zum Saisonende haben, die man auch noch zahlen muss, dass es finanziell nicht gut besser werden wird, weil es gibt jetzt nicht so viele Spieler, die man verkaufen kann und es gibt auch nicht viele Ansätze, dass man am Ende irgendwie Achter wird, um mit dem Fernsehgeld-Ranking zu klettern. Ja, man muss sich extrem, extrem große Sorgen machen und damit bin ich dann auch am Ende. Helmut Hack, mancher kennt ihn noch, der große Macher hinter der Spielvereinigung, jahrelang Präsident und alles Mögliche hier in diesem Verein. Der Mann, der diesen Verein gerettet und groß gemacht hat, hat auf der Jahreshauptversammlung nach sieben Jahren quasi im Ruhestand eine flammende Rede gehalten, 13 Minuten lang. Und die Essenz dessen war, dass die Spielvereinigung in einer großen Krise ist und er sich große Sorgen um seinen Verein macht. Also er hat sich nach sieben Jahren zum ersten Mal öffentlich zu Wort gemeldet, um zu sagen, wir sind in einer großen Krise. Ich glaube, das zeigt ganz gut, wie es um diesen Verein steht.
Einmal kurz noch zu Vogel, weil du eben schon gesagt hast, Verträge etc. Er hat plus Assistenten ein Vertrag bis Sommer 2027. Ja, ich weiß, kaum ein Trainer unterschreibt noch einen Vertrag bis zum Ende der Saison. Verstehe ich auch irgendwie. Aber 2027 ist halt dann auch noch mal anderthalb Jahre. Also, Entschuldigung, da verschluck ich mich selber an meinem Schreck. Also es ist schon nicht gut. Und ich kann ja auch einfach sagen, aus Bielefelder Sicht, das hatten wir hier auch mal, dass man so viele Trainer und generell Transfermiese, Transferverbindlichkeiten hatte. Heißer Tipp, einfach ins DFB-Pokalfinale kommen. Dann sieht das auf einmal ganz rosig aus. Ich war vergangenen Montag auf der harmonischsten Jahreshauptversammlung, die ich jemals mitbekommen habe. Vielleicht ganz gut, dass es mal eine erste Nacht ist, der mich verloren hat. Aber das ist schon wirklich übel und man muss halt auch einfach sagen, führt dann natürlich auch in Franken, mit Nürnberg als Nachbar, wahrscheinlich dann auch nicht so wunderbaren Position, da irgendwie noch groß was rauszuholen. Obwohl man, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, vor allem von der Ultraszene wurde diese Kampagne gefahren. Generell gibt es ja schon länger diese Kampagne zurück zur Spielvereinigung. Fürth, um darüber abstimmen zu lassen, das soll nächstes Jahr auf der Jahreshauptversammlung stattfinden. Ja, guck mal.
Soll ich kurz reingerätschen? Bitte. Ich versuche mich ganz, ganz kurz zu halten, weil es da auch neue Entwicklungen gibt, die vielleicht manche und manchen interessieren könnten. Also ja, seit 2018 gibt es eben diese Initiative, die sich dafür einsetzt, zum traditionellen Vereinsnamensspiel, vor allem Fürth, zurückzukehren. Und die hat im Sommer, ich glaube im Juli war es, eine Pressekonferenz abgehalten, in der sie erklärt hat, dass sie im November 2026 über den Vereinsnamen abstimmen möchte. Was den Hintergrund hat, dass man ein Jahr Mitglied sein muss, satzungsgemäß, um an Abstimmungen teilzunehmen. Deshalb noch nicht in diesem Jahr, sondern im kommenden Jahr. Und es gab offenbar auch sehr viele Gespräche im Hintergrund. Und beides Jahres Hauptversammlung gab es interessante Entwicklungen. Also im Bilanzpressegespräch vorher hat Holger Schwiewagner, der Geschäftsführer, schon gesagt, dass er sich dafür einsetzen würde, keinen Konfrontativen, sondern einen einen Weg dahin zu finden. Das heißt ja, dass offenbar die Gremien auch dazu zu der Überzeugung gekommen sind, dass sie diesen Weg mitgehen würden zur Spielfeierung Fürth zurück. Ein Thema, das seit sieben Jahren schwelt, das den Verein natürlich auch gewissermaßen lämt, weil es Kapazitäten auf Fan- wie Vereinsseite bindet. Und dann hat auch Helmut Hack, der, ja, also der Macher hinter dem Konstrukt Spielfeierung und Greuther Fürth, dass er landläufig dann nur als Greuther Fürth bekannt ist, zwar nicht direkt, aber indirekt in seinen Worten gesagt, dass er damit auch, sagen wir mal, fein wäre, wenn das so weit kommt. Er würde respektieren, wenn der Verein anders heißt, hat er gesagt. Und das ist für Menschen mit 76 Jahren, die an so was hängen. Sie sagen, sie respektieren, das ist ihr Einverständnis, es zu tun. Und auch der Oberbürgermeister der Stadt hat sogar gesagt, er würde sich auch für einen einen Weg einsetzen. Deswegen gab es auch jetzt in der vergangenen Woche ein Step mit dieser Initiative, dass man doch sehr erfreut sei, dass es einen einen Weg geben soll, dass man jederzeit für Gespräche bereit stünde. Also es könnte sein, dass dieser Verein vielleicht in einem Jahr ein anderer Namen trägt. Aber das ist jetzt vielleicht gerade nicht das große Problem, weil es gibt noch etwas dringendere Probleme, sportlicher wie finanzieller Art.
Aber man muss ja auch sagen, der EV konnte 2000 neue Mitglieder gewinnen. Also rein von der Größe von Fürth her ist das, glaube ich, auch, ich meine, auch mit Mitgliedern kann man zumindest für den EV durch Mitgliederbeiträge ein bisschen Geld generieren. Und ich glaube, das ist schon mal gut. Und wenn ich es auch richtig gelesen habe, es waren so viele Teilnehmerinnen bei der JHV wie noch nie mit über 500.
590, ja, also fast 600 schon, ja.
Also ich glaube, da waren im Bielefeld weniger.
Das hat natürlich mit der sportlichen Krise auch zu tun. Noch ganz kurz dazu, es gab einen offenen Brief der Fanszene, den würde ich jetzt gar nicht groß zitieren, da wurden viele Fragen gestellt und man hat sich große Sorgen gemacht. Und der Verein hat darauf geantwortet und hat die JHV als ersten Austausch dazu auserkoren. Deswegen waren da wahrscheinlich auch sehr viele Menschen da, die aufgrund der sportlichen Situation kommen wollten. Aber ja, man hat den Fürzig lang gesträubt gegen neue Mitglieder und Mitgliederinnen. Und jetzt klappt es, aber der Großteil davon ist tatsächlich in der Fan-Abteilung eingetreten, die auf knapp 2000 Leute mittlerweile angewachsen ist. Also weil halt viele einfach diesen Vereinsnamen ändern wollen. Das ist ein riesiges Thema in Fürth, das kann man außerhalb von Fürth immer schwerlich begreifen. Aber ich bin auch in Fürth geboren, in meinem Ausfall steht Fürth. Und wenn ich dann auswärts bin und der Stadionsprecher sagt, wie glaube ich in Bielefeld auch und auf Schalke, aus Kräuter Fürth, dann sage ich, nein, das steht nicht in meinem Ausweis, ich komme aus Fürth und nicht aus Kräuter Fürth. Deswegen geht es ja auch um andere elementare Dinge, wie Identität und Verbundenheit zu einem Verein. Also es würde noch viel weitergehen. Und wenn Fürth was fehlt, dann ist es gerade Identität als sportliche Art, aber auch insgesamt als Verein. Insofern finde ich das auch unterstützenswert, dieses Thema. Aber man sollte erst mal jetzt das Sportliche in den Griff kriegen. Es ist deutlich dringender.
Also ich kann aus Erfahrung sagen, es ist immer wichtig, wenn Fans das Gefühl haben, sie kriegen auch eine Stimme. Also beziehungsweise, ich meine, klar kann dann auch ein Verein sagen, ja hier, dann kommt doch zum Mitgliederversammlung, dann können wir darüber reden. Und dann taucht halt keiner auf. Also es zeigt ja auch, dass eben den Fürtheren dieser Verein nicht egal ist. Und das mag vielleicht manchen Spielern auf dem Platz dann relativ egal sein. Aber so schlecht, wie die finanzielle Situation ist. Aber ich meine, wenn Stefan Führsner erst wochenlang sagt, nee, nee, also hier, ich gehe hier nicht von meiner Entscheidung weg. Und dann halt doch irgendwann auch sagt, okay, aber so geht es nicht weiter. Das wird auch andere Gründe haben. Wir wissen immer nie, was so ein Aufsichtsrat da auch noch rein zu sagen hat. Bzw. Michi weiß im Zweifel schon, ich von außen jetzt nicht. Das klingt dann immer so doof, aber es ist vielleicht dann doch so ein Segway rein in, es kann vielleicht noch besser werden. Also 37 Gegentore ist eine Hypothek. Das ist ungefragt so und man muss leider auch sagen, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man zwölf davon abziehen könnte und sagen könnte, die kriegen sie halt auch so einfach. Ich glaube, selbst laut XG sind sie da leider nicht so ganz weit von entfernt, von dem, was sie hätten bekommen sollen.
Und sie sind nach XG, also nach Expected Goals Against die schlechtesten und nach Expected Goals die schlechtesten. Das sind auch das keine guten Werte und nach Expected Points über diese Metri kann man ja auch streiten. Sie sind auch die schlechteste Mannschaft der Liga und damit auch auf Platz 18. Damit nähert man sich halt einfach dem an, was auch statistisch so ist. Ich wurde dafür oft angefallen, so den Fürth, wenn ich Statistiken angeführt habe, aber wir haben ja alle gelernt, dass es die berühmte Regression zur Mitte gibt. Und wenn man halt in allem schlecht ist, dann ist man irgendwann auch faktisch in allem schlecht. Und das ist man halt jetzt leider gerade– wir könnten noch so viel reden über Fürth, aber ich glaube, wir müssen einfach warten, was der Psycho-Vogel da mit anfängt. Ich habe ein bisschen ganz leichte Alexander Zorniger-Wipes. Da stand es ja auch ganz schlecht um Fürth. Da war man auf Platz 18 und dann kam ein erfahrener Trainer, der im Ausland mal Erfolge hatte mit Brünnbi und Liemersoll. Und dann hat man– Eva, du erinnerst dich vielleicht, das erste Spiel gegen eine gewisse Arminia aus Bielefeld gleich gewonnen und danach noch zwei weitere Spiele und dann noch mal in Braunschweig und dann zu Hause noch gegen den HSV und einen unentschiedenen Darmstadt und zack, hatte man zehn Punkte mehr. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr bis zur Winterpause. Aber wir wissen alle, ein Spiel gegen einen angeschlagenen Asniff zu Nürnberg, bei dem der beste Torschütze fehlt, bei dem vielleicht der Sechser ausfällt, ein neuer Trainer in Fürth. Ich will nicht zu viel Euphorie haben, weil es ist Fürth, aber damit kann man natürlich auch ein Statement setzen und damit würde auch man mehr als eine Trendumkehr schaffen. Derby letzte Saison haben wir oft genug betont 0 zu 4, 0 zu 3. Alle Fürther haben das ins Mark getroffen. Wenn man da in Nürnberg mindestens mal nicht verliert, mit guter Leistung vielleicht einen Punkt holt oder sogar gewinnt, dann sieht die Stimmungslage schon wieder anders aus. Dann kommt zwar die Hertha. Die ist ziemlich gut, aber dann spielt man auch bei Fortuna Düsseldorf. Damit könnte ich dir jetzt auch eine Brücke bauen, Eva. Aber ich wollte noch ganz kurz auch etwas über die Haufei Bochum sagen. Genau. Ich war gespannt. Oder willst du Anna erst oder soll ich noch mein Monolog fortsetzen?
Ich kann gerne ein bisschen was sagen. Ja, mach doch mal. Obwohl, will ich jetzt schon was sagen? Also ich finde, Uwe Rösler hat ja zu einem sehr ähnlichen Datum wie einen Trainer seinen Amt übernommen, über den wir heute auch noch sprechen werden. Und es ist so ein bisschen das erfolgreiche Gegenstück. Und beides freut mich, muss ich sagen. Also der Erfolg des einen, aber no offence, auch der Misserfolg des anderen. Ja, genau. Und möchte sagen, weil wir ja viel so Referenzen ziehen zu den Vereinen, die wir am besten kennen, worum sich da langfristig unten nicht und warum sich die langfristig da unten nicht, weil sie Standards einfach zu Toren machen. Das ist nicht besonders wunderschön. Und vielleicht nicht so der spielerische Weg raus, wie ihn Magdeburg anstrebt, aber brutal effektiv, also nur einmal verloren. Und also seit Uwe Rösler im Amt ist. Und ich glaube, dass sie da eine gute Entscheidung getroffen haben. Und dass sie da mittelfristig, wenn sie die Nerven weiter behalten, relativ zügig den Weg auch rausfinden.
Ja, da hat man auch ganz klar gesehen jetzt in Fürth. Also diese Freistöße von Maxi Wittek, die waren wirklich, also es war jeder Standard wurde gefährlich, weil allein schon der Schütze einen gefährlichen Standard fabriziert hat. Ich erinnere mich an einen Verein, den ich da auch abspielen sehen, bei dem die meisten Standards nicht gefährlich werden, weil die Schüsse schon oder die Flanken und Heringaben schon nicht gut sind. Also da hat man einen guten Standardschütze, man hat natürlich auch Spieler mit einer gewissen Größe. Wenn Philipp Hofmann den spielt, er hat den auch nicht immer gespielt in diesem Spiel, hat er gespielt. Sissoko hat wieder nach langer Ausfallzeit zum ersten Mal wieder vom Beginn an gespielt, hat auch eine gute Größe. Also man hat da Spieler, man wird es natürlich nicht jede Woche so leicht haben, wie in Fürth Tore zu schießen nach Standards, aber man hat es eben gemacht und damit hat man ja mit den ersten zwei Standard-Toren nach 13 Minuten war das Spiel eigentlich entschieden, dass das dritte noch kam, hat dann den Deckel drauf gemacht, aber Fürth wäre auch nach 0-2 nicht mehr zurückgekommen. Dafür ist zu vieles kaputt gegangen hier. Und ich fand sie auch ansonsten sehr stabil. Also klar, sie mussten nicht mehr viel machen, weil Fürth auch nichts mehr gemacht hat, kamen den Buche mal ganz gelegen, weil sie ein Pokalspiel unter der Woche haben. Also konnten sie sich dafür auch schonen, mussten glaube ich nur 113 Kilometer laufen oder so. Also für zweitig her verhältnis jetzt gar nicht mal so viel. Und ansonsten auch, wie Anna schon sagte, Uwe Rösler hat, glaube ich, vier von sechs Spielen gewonnen, einmal unentschieden, einmal verloren, dann hat er das gewonnen, auch drei der letzten vier Spiele gewonnen. Dazwischen diese, warum auch immer, nicht erklärbare Niederlage gegen Dynamo Dresden, auf die wir gleich auch noch kommen. Aber ansonsten sieht es trotzdem stabil aus. Interessant doch bei Bochum, dass man ja schon einen gewissen Jugendstil hat. Und Jeka zum Beispiel hat jetzt auch wieder gespielt, da gibt es auch andere Spieler noch. Ich will gar nicht alle aufzählen, aber man hat dann auch vielversprechende Talente hochgezogen, die mittlerweile beim VfL spielen. Junge Elan, der dann mit dazu gekommen ist, gepaart mit der Erfahrung, die man hat mit Hofmann, mit Wittek, mit natürlich auch Holtmann noch, der sich in Fürth leider verletzt hat, mit Noah Losli, der letztes Jahr in Fürth noch teilweise auch wirklich gute Spiele gemacht hat in der Abwehr, Strompf als Hühner, der in der Abwehr da hinten drin steht, letztes Jahr noch in Ulm, der aber auch offensiv gefährlich werden kann bei Standards. Also das ist keine Absteigermannschaft, die ich gesehen habe, auf keinen Fall. Und ich habe sie als Aufstiegskandidaten getippt, das könnte eng werden. Da müsste Uwe Rösler schon mit seinem Punkteschnitt bislang weitermachen, dann könnte es noch klappen, weil jetzt ist ziemlich gut der Punkteschnitt. Und man kann davon halten, was man will, aber auch seine Art verfängt ja auch. Also er ist entführt auch wieder, rausgerannt und hat da vor dem Gestirrbox seinen Jubel-Tanz aufgeführt. Und dann ist es VfL. Ich war gerade noch im Pressepistool, habe mir einen Kaffee geholt. Und dann plötzlich habe ich ihn so laut da draußen. Dann habe ich gemerkt, ja, Uwe Rösler ist gerade zur Fan-Kurve gelaufen. Und er kam dann auch nach dem Spiel in den Kabinen gang und hat einfach in der Mixed-Zone für die Journalisten einfach einen, ich mache es nicht nach, sonst fliegen alle Hörhörer in die Ohren weg, einen, ja, reingebrüllt. Also es ist, sagen wir mal, sehr exuberantiert. Aber das kann ja nicht schaden, wenn man damit auch so ein, es ist trotzdem ein euphorisches Umfeld, sondern ein leicht zu begeisterndes Umfeld in Bochum, wenn man das damit wieder ein bisschen anzündet. Also, nee, da werden andere Vereine bis zum Ende gegen den Abstieg spielen als der VfL.
Das macht ein bisschen die Bo-Henriksen-Vibes. Aus der letzten Saison. Ich glaube, niemand möchte Bo-Henriksen-Vibes aus dieser Saison haben, weil, ich sag mal so, ich sehe durchaus auch Ähnlichkeiten von Mainz 05 und der Spielvereinigung Fürth, außer dass Fürth nicht in der Conference League spielt und in anderthalb Wochen zu gleich posen muss.
Dann möchte ich auch nicht.
Komisch. Nee, also generell würde ich sagen, ich bin, also ich glaube, es ist vielen emotional gerade eben auch. Uwe Rösler natürlich auch der absolute Gegenpol zu Davor Dieter Hecking. Da könnten auch nicht mehr Welten zwischendurch liegen. Ich bin halt immer so ein bisschen vorsichtig. Das mag daran liegen, dass sich solche Art Trainer mich irgendwie einfach nicht so bekommen. Genauso bei Lukas Kwaßniok oder so. Ich finde das irgendwie immer so ein bit too much, auch da immer mit kurzer Hose zu stehen. Keine Ahnung, ist mir ein bisschen zu viel. Aber man muss halt einfach sagen, also das, was wir vor der Saison oder auch im Laufe der Saison kritisiert haben, dass man auch das Gefühl hat, der Kader, der funktioniert überhaupt nicht zusammen. Da hängen keine... Die Mannschaftsteile funktionieren überhaupt nicht. Die Neuverpflichtungen funktionieren nicht. Stand jetzt, sage ich, wenn Alfa Rubrecht jetzt auch noch anfängt, Tore zu schießen, dann wird es auch nochmal weiter eng, weil gerade er und Unieker natürlich auch gerade in diesem 4-2-3-1-System, was Rösler eigentlich so fest etabliert hat. Ich glaube, er hat nur im Pokal gegen Augsburg mit einem 4-1-1-System gespielt. Es klappt einfach ganz gut, eben schneller Außenspieler zu haben. Du hast ein festes Zentrum und dann hast du eine Spitze vorne. Das funktioniert sehr gut. Ich war auch nicht davon ausgegangen, dass Bochum jetzt unten drin bleibt. Es stand jetzt Platz 12, 16 Punkte, 20 zu 20 Tore. Man gleicht sich da eben gerade ein bisschen auf. Es hat halt eben noch die Hypothek von acht Niederlagen, aber inzwischen eben auch fünf Siege und in den letzten fünf Spielen drei Siege und entschieden eine Niederlage. Dieses Spiel gegen Dresden kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht erklären, bevor wir über den Dynamo gleich noch sprechen. Aber ja, also wie gesagt, Punkteschnitt von 2,29. Michi, du hast eben gesagt, das ist ein sehr guter Punkteschnitt. Das ist die Zahl dazu. Und ja, also ich bin mal gespannt. Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz, was passiert, wenn bei Bochum dann doch noch mal auch unter Rößler eine Niederlagenserie eintritt, weil da, wo es emotional hochgehen kann, kann es emotional eben auch sehr schnell wieder runtergehen. Das ist eben das Problem. Aber ich glaube, sie sind jetzt erstmal aus dem Größten raus. Ich sehe trotzdem weiterhin nicht– also es hatten Leute, die ja auch als Aussteiger getippt. Ich glaube, das ist eine Konsolidierung. So geht das Wort nicht. Egal. Für mich ist es die 800. Stunde heute.
Konsolidierung.
Dankeschön. Konsolidierung. Dankeschön. Voll freundlich von dir. Das heißt, erstmal schauen– wir haben es schon oft gesehen, dass es eben auch nochmal sehr viel schlimmer kommen kann als Absteiger. Von daher ist es, glaube ich, erstmal– es lässt sich viel über Kiel sagen gleichzeitig. Und ich glaube, da sind sie jetzt schon in einem ruhigeren Fahrwasser angekommen. Und auch da noch eine Info. Auch da war die Jahreshauptversammlung Tis the Season. Wer mehr dazu wissen will, dem empfehle ich jetzt einfach mal ganz richtig die Episode des 1848 Podcasts. Die Folge verlinke ich euch in den Show Notes, aber die können euch mehr darüber erzählen, was es da vielleicht auch für Neuerungen geben soll. Es steht jetzt eben mal dieses Highlight-Spiel an, zu Hause im DFB-Vokal gegen den VfB Stuttgart. Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf, ehrlich gesagt. Einfach mal gucken, was Stuttgart so bei eigenen Standards macht, dann könnte das ganz gut werden. Und dann zu Hause gegen Aminia Bielefeld, da freue ich mich am Samstag doch drauf. Ganz uneigennützig hoffe ich auf so eine richtig, richtig schwierige Partie gegen Stuttgart. Warum wohl? Weiß niemand. Na ja, habt ihr zu den beiden Teams noch zu sagen oder wollen wir zum letzten Spiel springen?
Meinetwegen können wir springen.
Sehr schön.
Springen wir.
Ja, springen wir aus dem Fürther Loch heraus nach Dresden. Na ja, da hat Dresden Fortuna Düsseldorf empfangen. Und dieses Spiel 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Tore von Rossipal und Fermé ausgerechnet, möchte man sagen. Sagt übrigens auch der Fortuna Social Media Manager, ich glaube auf X noch, das ausgerechnet Fermé, ja das 2-0 machte Rasmussen. Der trifft zwar noch spät für die Fortuna, reicht aber am Ende nicht. Und es kommt eher noch dicke für Dynamo Dresden, denn Torhüter Krüll, Grill verletzt sich stark, wird wegen schwerer Knieverletzung mehrere Monate fehlen. Und obwohl dann einer der Feldspieler der Dresden da ins Tor muss, weil kein Wechsel mehr frei war, kann Düsseldorf daraus nichts mehr machen. Das ist jetzt der zweite Sieg in Folge für die Dresdener, eben nach dem 1-0-Sieg beim VfL Bochum, ein 2-1-Heimaufwärm gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf, gerade glaube ich in der Tabellenkonstellation nicht so schlecht. Michi, ich würde mal mit dir anfangen. Es gibt auch ein Thema neben dem Platz, das würde ich jetzt erst mal kurz noch nach hinten schieben. Findest du denn, dass Dresden jetzt doch langsam zeigt, was sie in der 2. Liga leisten könnten?
Ganz offensichtlich. Man kann sagen, Dynamo lebt. Das ist ja die schönste Erkenntnis für alle Menschen, deren Herz an Dynamo Dresden hängt. Also es sah lange dann schon traurig aus. Ich habe sie am ersten Spieltag in Fürth sehen. Da haben sie, fand ich, auch immer schlechte Ansätze gehabt, auch fußballerisch. Da hatte ich damals Sorgen um die Defensive. Jetzt haben sie von allen Teams unten im Tabellenkehler die beste Torreferenz. Das haben sie auch ein bisschen in den Griff bekommen. Und klar, sie haben gewonnen in Bochum, die vor dem Spieltag 13 Punkte hatten und haben jetzt gewonnen gegen Bochum und Düsseldorf, die ebenfalls im Tabellenkehler feststecken. Also damit gegen zwei unmittelbare Konkurrenten gewonnen. Das sind Siege, die vielleicht sogar doppelt wichtig sind, auch wenn sie erst mal nur drei Punkte bringen. Aber sie bringen ja auch mindestens mal keine Punkte für die andere Mannschaft, die unten drin hängt. Insofern, klar, die Verletzung von Lennart Krillers so angesprochen, die tut schon weh. Man hat mit ihm einen Torhüter gefunden, das wurde nachher auch so betont, der wirklich auch Sicherheit ausstrahlt. Herr Anna und ich werden uns wundern, dass er das bei Dynamo so tun kann, weil in Braunschweig und in Fürth hat er das nicht immer getan. In Fürth hat jetzt nicht so viel gespielt, aber da war er als Ersatztorhüter hier, aber hat jetzt auch nicht immer die glücklichste Figur abgegeben. Bei Dynamo kann das offenbar, gönne ich ihm auch, nach doch langer Leidenszeit an verschiedenen Standorten. Aber er war für Dynamo ein guter Torhüter, der fällt jetzt erstmal aus und vermutlich auch länger. Also so wie die, ich meine, ich sehe ihn nicht nochmal sehen, die tat wirklich beim Zuschauen schon weh und hat Dynamo und er selbst, haben sie beide auch dann erwähnt, dass es vermutlich eine längere Ausfallzeit sein wird. Aber man kann sagen, die Moral stimmt auf jeden Fall. Und man hat halt jetzt in dem Spiel gesehen, es war der erste Heimsieg, das ist auch krass. Also wenn man dieses Stadion sieht, diese Begeisterungsfähigkeit, gefühlt gibt es jedes Spiel eine Ikoria im Kaplok und seit 25.000 Menschen schreien sich die Seele aus dem Leib. Das kann schon noch ein Vorteil im Abstiegskampf sein, wenn man jetzt auch schafft, zu Hause da dann Gegner zu bezwingen. Die Torreferenz habe ich gerade schon genannt mit den Minus 6. Ich habe auch schon ein bisschen Sorge, am 17. Januar zum Rückgrundenauftakt spielt Fürth bei Dynamo Dresden. Dresden ist jetzt in Form mit einem lautstarken Rudolf-Hawik-Stadion und mit einer gewissen Wucht. Schauen wir mal. Aber ich glaube für alle Dresdnerinnen und Dresdner eine sehr schöne 2 Wochen jetzt, oder eine schöne Woche, zwischen diesen beiden Fußballspielen.
Ich bin tatsächlich mal sehr gespannt, weil eine defensive Stabilität, die am Anfang nicht da war, die dann irgendwann kam, wenn betont wird, Grill, ist schon so Backup. Ich möchte jetzt dem Ersatztorhüter von Dresdner gar nicht zu nahe treten, aber es ist natürlich schon eine Frage, ob man sich so weit stabilisiert hat, dass die Kette davor das auffangen kann, oder dass man sagt, was passiert jetzt, wenn wir einen neuen Torhüter drin haben, man muss sich erstmal einspielen. Das dauert vielleicht kurz, ob da diese gleiche Stabilität wiederkommt, oder ob man da eventuell ein alter Muster verfällt. Es ist natürlich viel, ja, hätte, wenn und aber. Aber da wäre jetzt gerade ein Punkt, dass, wie gesagt, diese Verletzung von Spielern ist sowieso nie cool, aber die kommen vielleicht wirklich zum genau falschen Zeitpunkt, ehrlich gesagt, weil du so ein leichtes Aufwärts hast. Anna, Dresden ist ja in zwei Spielen, also man spielt jetzt erst zu Hause gegen den FCK, äh, auswärts beim FCK und dann eben zu Hause gegen Braunschweig. Also es gibt dieses Aufeinandertreffen, was kannst du schon mal so vielleicht ankündigen, was du dafür ein Spiel erwartest? Einfach, einfach mal so als Wild-Gaz in den Raum geworfen.
Na, ich bin tatsächlich sehr gespannt, weil sich das ja jetzt am letzten Wochenende sehr gezeigt hat, wie wichtig wirklich jeder Punkt ist, wenn ich die Phrase Dreschen drauf, wie wichtig der Sieg für die Braunschweige Eintracht war, weil die Konkurrenz halt einfach nachgezogen hat oder, ja, bis auf Fürth, Entschuldigung, ich wollte nicht aus Versehen, hier Salz in Wunden streuen, habe ich aber gemacht. Ja, das Spiel, ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Braunschweige Eintracht sich wegentwickeln möchte von Hinten stehen, warten, kontern und denke, dass wir auf eine Mannschaft treffen, die gerne spielt, die gerne das Spiel gestaltet, was ich für einen Aufsteiger gar nicht so gewöhnlich finde. Wir haben ja auch wirklich sehr ordentliche Leistungen gesehen von Dynamo Dresden gegen Hannover 96 beispielsweise, 2-2, auch gegen Elbersberg 2-2 gespielt. Also nur weil die da im unteren Bereich der Tabelle stehen, heißt das nicht, dass sie ihre Füße nicht sortiert bekommen. Und gehe davon aus, dass das ein Spiel sein wird, das wirklich sehr offen ist. Also kann ich jetzt im Vorfeld nicht ausmachen, wer da in meinen Augen der Favorit sein könnte. Weil ich glaube, dass beide, wie es so schön heißt, den Abstiegskampf angenommen haben und sich da durchaus aufopferungsvoll geben werden, um nicht zuletzt, irgendwie auch im vorletzten Spiel des Jahres vielleicht noch ein paar Punkte zu sammeln und dann eben auch vielleicht ein bisschen Abstand zur Konkurrenz aufbauen zu können. Das werden sehr, sehr spannende Wochen für den Tabellenkeller.
Ja, da würde ich mitgehen. Einmal, ich habe eben einmal schon erwähnt, dass es Vorfallen neben dem Platz gab. Es gab rassistische Ausfälle von Teilen des Dresdner Publikums gegenüber Emanuel Iyoa von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Muss man erstens sagen, sehr gut reagiert vom Schiedsrichter gespannt. Die haben eben den 3-Stufen-Plan aktiviert. Es gab eine Durchsage im Stadion unter anderem und man muss sagen, erstens sehr gute Reaktion von Thomas Stamm, also dem Trainer von Dynamo Dresden im Anschluss. Ich lese einmal kurz vor, was er genau gesagt hat. Ich habe die Bitte an diese Zuschauer, nicht mehr ins Stadion zu kommen. Sie haben mir nichts verloren, aber auch grundsätzlich nichts in der Gesellschaft. So etwas macht mich sprachlos. Die Leute können daheim bleiben und die, die drum herum sitzen, können so mutig sein, damit man weiß, wer es ist. Das finde ich tatsächlich ein enorm gutes Statement von Stamm, weil mich das manchmal stört, wenn Leute dann einfach nur sagen, ja das gehört hier nicht ins Stadion. Nee, es ist nämlich genau das. Das sollte nirgendwo in der Gesellschaft Platz haben. Und eben auch dieser Aufruf, sich dagegen zu äußern. Merke vielleicht manchmal auch, Thomas Stamm war in Freiburg lange, ist da eben natürlich auch, glaube ich, auch sensibilisiert worden, anders nochmal für das Thema. Aber auch Dynamo hat danach bei X geschrieben, dieses Zitat bedarf keiner weiteren Erklärung, Love, Dynamo, Hate, Racism. Bevor wir gleich zu den Aussagen von Markus Anfang auf der anderen Seite kommen, der ungefragter, sich, glaube ich, eher ein wenig in, ja gut gesagt, die Scheiße geritten hat, muss ich einfach sagen, ich meine, ich habe Dresden die letzten zwei Jahre eben als Gegner mitverfolgt. Es war natürlich gerade gegen Markus Anfang, den Ex-Trainer, der halt eben es nicht geschafft hat, zwei Jahre in Folge mit Dynamo Dresden aufzusteigen. Ich habe reinfilmt, für ein, zwei Dynamo-Fans war das vielleicht auch noch mal eine– oder auch für Dynamo-Spieler war das noch mal eine extra Portion, Motivation. Aber ich muss generell einfach sagen, also das, was Dresden auch zum Teil gespielt hat, das war das, was sie in der 3. Liga auch schon stark gemacht haben, was sie eben nicht immer geschafft haben, in der 2. Liga auf den Platz zu bringen, wo man halt durchaus zu Recht schon gefragt hat, haben sie genug Qualität für die 2. Liga auf dem Rasen? Haben sie da Verfehlungen gemacht in der Transfer-Fenster eben auch oder in der Transferphase? Per se ist das, glaube ich, ihr habt es gesagt, mit dem Rudolf-Hawik-Stadion, das kann immer in beide Richtungen gehen, das merkt man auch immer. Also das kann eine absolute Faustwand sein, es kann ja aber auch, ehrlich gesagt, das Leben noch ein bisschen schwerer machen. Gerade jetzt, ich glaube, sie tragen eben, sind eben auch noch auf dieser Ausstiegseuphorie, sieht das ganz gut aus. Generell bin ich mal gespannt. Also sie sind jetzt eben über einen Strich auf Platz 15. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, ob sie das halten können. Ich meine, sie waren, ich kann das ja auch sagen, sie waren ja auch bei mir Abstiegskandidat, weil ich mir eben nicht vorgestellt habe, dass sie es über die 34 Spieltage schaffen, sich da anzupassen. Aber momentan zeigt da die Formkurve auch auf jeden Fall nach oben und ich weiß, ich sag das immer, ihr könnt es alle nicht mehr hören, aber es ist einfach so, gerade in einer Situation eine Serie aufzubauen. Ich glaube, das wird denen ganz gut tun. Und Braunschweig hat ja gerade zum Beispiel beim FCK die Fehler offengelegt. Spielweisen kann man nicht vergleichen, von daher würde ich nicht sagen, das kannst du eins zu eins übertragen, aber das war ganz ordentlich bisher in dem Spiel.
Ja, das stimmt. Das kann man, denke ich, so festhalten. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich denke, Kaiserslautern ist für Ausschläge nach oben und unten bekannt. Und Dresden jetzt mit zwei Siegen im Rücken, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das spannend wird. Also, ich finde, die 2. Liga funktioniert sowieso über vor allem Serien. Also, im Prinzip brauchst du ja nur 3, 4 immerhin Siegesserien und du hältst die Klasse. Und oft ist es ja auch so, dass es nicht so ein kompletter Fleckenteppich von Siegniederlage unentschieden ist, sondern dass halt die Mannschaften, die die Klasse halten, einfach über längere Zeiten ihre Siege einfahren und am Ende haut es irgendwie hin. Wer weiß, vielleicht war jetzt das Wochenende tatsächlich der ausschlaggebende Punkt dafür, dass Dresden in die Spur nach oben findet und Kaiserslautern jetzt bis zum Winter ein bisschen schlingert. Es ist ja auch kein Umfeld ohne Erwartungshaltung. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da vielleicht ein bisschen Höhenangst zwischenzeitlich aufgekommen ist, wenn man zu viel von ganz oben geträumt hat.
Ja, und von ganz oben geträumt ist ehrlich gesagt auch ein gutes Stichwort, führt dann auch den letzten Verein, über den wir sprechen, mit Michael, aufzulachen. Ihr baut mir meine Vorlagen hier.
Ich musste nur an meine Aufstiegstipps denken. Ein Buchum, Düsseldorf und so. Die waren da alles sehr weit oben. Deswegen sollte man sich nicht als Fußball-Experten bezeichnen.
Auf jeden Fall soll es eben um Fortuna Düsseldorf gehen. Da ist es Platz 14. Also sie stehen noch über Dynamo Dresden. 14 Punkte in der Formtabelle. Zuletzt ist man allerdings auf Platz 15. Und sowieso allgemein zuletzt jetzt nicht so das Beste. Also man hat 3 Siege erst geholt. 4 Siege geholt bei unentschieden 8 Niederlagen. Das ist enorm viel. Und wir haben ja glaube ich vor einem Monat schon mal darüber gesprochen. Und man muss sagen, so wahnsinnig viel hat sich jetzt nicht verbessert. Unter Markus Anfang. Erst ein Sieg gegen den ersten FC Magdeburg, da haben wir schon darüber gesprochen. War jetzt auch nicht so, dass man sagen muss, das müssen sie unbedingt gewinnen. Dann gab es noch einen unentschiedenen Kaiserslautern. Sonst hat man alle Spiele verloren. Anna, ich sehe im Unterschied zu Daniel Tune keinerlei Verbesserung in dem Kader. Lass uns erst einmal ein bisschen auf Sportliche gucken. Woran hapert es für dich denn, vor allem bei Fortuna momentan?
Ja, an allem. Ich finde, der auffälligste Spieler ist immer wieder Florian Kastenmaier, weil ich bei ihm so am ehesten das Gefühl habe, der wehrt sich so richtig gegen das, was da gerade einfach ist und seit Wochen auch ist. Auf dem Platz und lautstark und mit Gestik und Körpersprache. Und die übrige Mannschaft wirkt jetzt– also natürlich sind die da und irgendwie machen sie auch mit, aber es wirkt, finde ich, kolossal, ich weiß gar nicht, irgendwie sowas wie unsortiert oder– also ich habe nicht das Gefühl. Dass da was passiert oder dass sich da was verändert oder auch nicht, dass da Fehlerquellen gefunden worden sind, die jetzt irgendwie nach und nach behoben werden. Sondern habe das Gefühl, dass es eher, dass die Mannschaft jetzt nach dem Trainerwechsel so ein bisschen auf sich zurückgeworfen wird, so nach dem Motto, naja, jetzt ist ja der Trainer weg. An dem hat es gelegen, jetzt müsste es ja funktionieren. Und nehme die Mannschaft als sehr, ja, also ungefährlich, würde ich sagen, wahr. Also es ist tatsächlich nicht das, was beide Trainer beschrieben haben nach dem Spiel gegen Dresden. Also wurde ja gesagt, es sei ausgeglichen gewesen und so weiter und so fort. Aber wenn man da jetzt so ein bisschen in vage Fahrwasser gehen darf, habe ich ein ganz anderes Gefahrengefühl, wenn wir über Dynamo Dresden sprechen im Vergleich zu Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Wir haben ja vor einigen Minuten schon über einen Verein gesprochen, mit dem man sich Sorgen machen muss. Ich glaube, auch um Düsseldorf muss man sich Sorgen machen. Im Forum hat dankenswerterweise ein User– ich glaube, er war männlich– die Formtabelle anders dargestellt, nämlich eine Anfangstabelle. Und damit ist in der ESMEN von sechs Spielen vier Punkte, fünf zu acht Tore auf Rang 17 in der Marcos Anfangstabelle. Und schlechter ist nur ein mir ganz gut bekannter Verein, der es noch schafft, die Fortuna zu unterbieten. Aber wenn Fürth nicht so schlecht wäre wie in den letzten Monaten, dann wäre man da auf Platz 18 und das nach einem Trainerwechsel. Also man hat ja den ersten Joker einer Mannschaft, die vielleicht nicht so performt, wie man das will, schon gezogen und steht jetzt schlechter da in der Tünetabelle, weil man deutlich weiter oben. Klar, man hat da ein Muster erkannt. Ich habe Düsseldorf auch letztes Jahr spielen sehen. Wir hatten das Thema auch schon öfter mal in diesem Format besprochen, dass da auch Spiele dabei waren, bei denen es mich wirklich gewundert hat. Und Daniel Tune dann irgendwann auch fast schon verzweifelt wirkte, manchmal auch ratlos wirkte. Trotzdem hat die Fortuna und die immer eine bessere Figur abgegeben, als es jetzt unter Markus Anfang tut. Natürlich ist eine sportlich und das andere auch, was die Außendarstellung angeht, Eva. Das wolltest du auch noch besprechen.
Ja, das sage ich gleich, ich muss eine Ergänzung noch machen. Also man muss auch sagen, mit Matthias Zimmermann, der schon Urfortuna was ist, möchte ich sagen, also seit 2018 im Verein fehlt jemand auf der rechtsverteidiger Position, weil Gell-Lunder fehlt, auch auf der rechtsverteidiger Position. Und mit Sotiris Alexandropoulos hast du auch einen Spieler, der die ersten neun Spiele durchgespielt hat und seitdem Muskelbündel hat und auch bis zum Ende des Jahres, also der ist in der Rückrunde wieder fit. Also das kommt eben auch dazu. Aber ich finde auch einfach, wenn du zum Beispiel auf das 1 zu 2 von Rasmussen guckst, also Rasmusens Gästik auch, das ist so er selbst so nach dem Tor so ein bisschen so ja, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, machen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr oder kommt da nichts? Und das finde ich so, ja natürlich kann man nicht alles über Körpersprache erzählen und darauf will ich diesen Sport auch überhaupt nicht begrenzen. Aber das ist so, also ich meine ihr zieht ja auch die Parallelen zu eurem Verein. Ich muss auch einfach sagen, ich habe sowas auch alle schon bei Bielefeld gesehen. Also einfach dieses, ja eigentlich müssten wir ja besser sein als das und wir haben ja Qualität und ja da hatten wir auch mal ein bisschen Pech. Aber das reicht nicht. Also einfach zu sagen, naja aber vom Selbstverständnis her wird es schon nicht der Abstiegskampf. Dann in meiner Anna, du hast es glaube ich eben so schön gesagt, zwei Mannschaften, die den Abstiegskampf angenommen haben. Ich sehe das bei Fortuna Düsseldorf nicht. Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, welcher Spieler es war, aber ich meine von, da gab es eben auch die Aussage, ja wir brauchen eh erst ab dem 20. Spieltag auf die Tabelle zu gucken. Ja, also wenn du, ist natürlich nicht der Fall, aber wenn du am 20. Spieltag abgeschlagen 18er bist, dann brauchst du nicht ab da auf die Tabelle zu gucken. Also weil dann geht es nämlich nach unten. Und das finde ich halt so fatal. Und ich muss jetzt gerade kurz das Original-Statement noch von Markus Anfang raussuchen, weil ich es mir hier natürlich nicht reinkopiert habe, so professionell wie ich bin. Gebt mir zwei Sekunden. Und zwar hieß es da zu dem Vorfall bei Dynamo, again, sein eigener Spieler ist betroffen, wenn der ein oder andere aus irgendeiner Emotion reinruft, das ist nicht schön, aber das dann zur Verallgemeinern ist auch ein bisschen schwierig. Das hilft unserem Fußball nicht und ist auch nicht schön für den Menschen.
Und das ganz kurz hat er ungefragt im Sky-Interview gesagt. Also es ist nicht– und das finde ich wichtig, wirklich doppelt zu unterstreichen –,Dass da niemand gesagt hat, wie sehen Sie das denn oder haben Sie da eine Meinung zu? Sondern er ist im nächsten Redeblock noch einmal reingegangen, um zu erwähnen, was du gerade zitiert hast. Und das finde ich– also wäre auch nicht besser, wenn er zum Dresdner Verein gehören würde. Aber ich finde es noch absurder in dem Moment, in dem er einfach die rhetorische Möglichkeit hätte, selbst wenn in seinem Kopf und um Gottes Willen, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, aber irgendwie eine leichte Tendenz in Richtung Unterstützung dessen, was da geäußert wurde, wo vorherrscht, hätte er einfach die Chance zu sagen, mein Spieler tut mir leid. Also es sind so viele Wege, das einfach smart zu lösen, wenn man sich da nicht zu äußern möchte. Und er hat keinen davon gefunden.
Ja, vor allem, ich weiß auch gar nicht, was er mit Menschen meint. Meint er da Ijoa mit? Oder meint er die Person, die rassistisch beleidigt hat? Also mit der habe ich an der Stelle vor allem sehr wenig mitleid. Und also, ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob Anfang da irgendwie versucht hat, eine Beziehung noch zu den Dresden-Fans zu kitten. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass es gut ankommt, so zu versuchen. Und man muss einfach sagen, also alleine immer, ich muss das an der Stelle nochmal deutlich sagen, Rassismus ist keine Emotion. Wenn dir aus der Emotion heraus etwas Diskriminierendes rausrutscht, ob das sexistisch, queerfeindlich oder rassistisch ist, dann ist das keine Emotion, sondern dann bist du eben ein Rassist, ein Sexist oder queerfeindlich. So. Und ich kann es nicht mehr hören, so was mit Emotionen zu entschuldigen. Und natürlich ist nicht ein ganzes Stadion an einer Person schuld. Und sowas wird es, auch wenn andere Vereine das nicht hören, es wird auch auf St. Pauli solche Rufe geben. Es ist natürlich immer der Unterschied, wie die Menschen drum herum reagieren. Und wir haben eben Thomas Stamm dafür gelobt, was er danach sagt. Und das zu hören und dann zu sagen, nee, ich muss das jetzt irgendwie anders frameen. Und wenn das dein Trainer ist und dein Trainer soll dich als Spieler schützen und alle schützen dich als Spieler außer dein eigener Trainer, ich hätte keinen Bock mehr unter dem zu spielen. Also das muss man einfach so sagen, wenn das das ist, was was rausgetragen wird und man kann ihm das nicht positiv einsehen und das hat auch nichts mit Verallgemeinerung zu tun, das ist einfach eine Katastrophe. Und das, ich meine, und dann muss man wirklich leider einfach sagen, ich weiß, dass immer wieder gesagt wurde, ja, aber diese Impfdebatte und etc. und PP und das soll man Markus Anfang doch nicht ewig nachtagen. Aber Markus Anfang in nichts, was er tut, spricht er dafür, dass man ihn auch neben dem Platz, als jemanden wahrnimmt, der, und das muss ich so hart sagen, auch junge Spieler beispielsweise entwickeln sollte, weil da– ne, also sorry für den emotionalen Ausbruch, aber sowas macht mich wirklich unfassbar sauer.
Ja, und ich finde das umso bemerkenswerter. Hatte mich damals schon über die Verpflichtung gewundert, gerade von den Hintergründen, die du gerade noch mal skizziert hast, weil ja Fortuna Düsseldorf mit so Kampagnen wie Fortuna für alle, freier Eintritt ins Stadion, erst mal nur für ein paar Spiele. Aber perspektivisch war eigentlich die Vision, halt barrierefreier im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, auch zahlungsfreier Zugang zum Stadion. Und das ist ja ein riesiges Statement, also das alle und auch zu anzuerkennen, dass es einfach für Leute schwer ist, sich ein Ticket zu leisten und so weiter und so fort. Also so der inklusive Überbau, wenigstens als Idee, den mal zu formulieren oder auch mal so einer Utopie nachzugehen. Und das, finde ich, steht in einem absurden Kontrast zu dieser Trainerposition. Das habe ich nicht verstanden und wirft umso mehr Fragen auf nach diesen Äußerungen jetzt am Wochenende, da würde ich mich dir in allen Punkten anschließen wollen, wirklich unsäglich finde und irgendwie mich dann auch frage, wie kommt das an bei dem Spieler, der da betroffen ist, bei der Mannschaft, die wahrscheinlich ihrem Mannschaftskameraden gegenüber solidarischer ist, als dem Trainer, der seit 6 Wochen da ist. Aber auch, wie bereitest du das als PR-Mensch auf? Wie gehst du mit so einer Personalie um? Das ist wirklich ein einziges Desaster.
Und daran anschließend auch noch, ich glaube, dass da wirklich extrem viel kaputtgegangen ist, man mehr verloren hat als ein Fußballspiel. Das eine ist das Binnenverhältnis, auch Mannschafts-Trainer. Dass man Menschen nicht schützt, dass da ein Mensch, der rassistisch beleidigt wurde, einfach keine Rückendeckung von seinem Trainer erfährt. Aber die Fortuna-Fanszene ist ja auch tendenziell eine sehr progressive und die sich gegen sehr viele Diskriminierungsformen einsetzt. Und wenn der eigene Trainer dann den Rassismus verharmlost und sportlich keinen Erfolg hat, kann das, glaube ich, auch schnell für ihn unangenehm werden. Was natürlich dann eine Rolle spielt, wenn vor allem die Ultra-Gruppen in Düsseldorf ganz klare politische Statements auch immer wieder setzen, was ja sehr schön und sehr erfreulich ist. Also, ein Gefallen hat sich Markus Anfang damit auf keinen Fall getan. Wird er wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch gemerkt haben, aber die Vielzahl an Ausfällen, die er sich leistet, da kann man irgendwann auch nicht mehr an Zufälle glauben. Also, entweder ist er schlecht beraten oder er kann und will es dann einfach nicht besser können. Aber beides sind keine guten Erkenntnisse. Und ja, wie Anna vorhin sagte, vielleicht ist dann da die Hoffnung, dass das mit schon einem Trainerwechsel in Düsseldorf, dass da eine Mannschaft bis zum Ende unten mitspielen wird, die dafür sorgt, dass ich nicht im April schon weiß, wer abgestiegen ist.
Ja, ich würde sagen, es wird spannend zu sehen sein, weil ich glaube, wir sind uns da auch alle einig darüber, dass Klaus Alofs da natürlich auch– wir haben ja schon mal drüber gesprochen– aber da natürlich gleichzeitig auch mit den Mittelpunkt rückt, weil er hat dann den Tune entlassen, er hat Markus Anfang verpflichtet. Ja, wo geht das auch ein bisschen, möchte ich sagen, auf seine Kappe. Und von daher im Endeffekt natürlich auch zuständig für die Kaderzusammenstellung etc., PP. Von daher, ja, und ich möchte auch sagen, zu Hause gegen Schalke und auswärts bei Elbersberg sind jetzt auch nicht die Partien, die ich mir in diesem Zustand wünschen wollen würde, als Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Aber, 17. Spieltag, 17. Spieltag. Heimspiel gegen Fürth.
Ja, ja.
Ja, da müsst ihr dann ran. Das ist dann ebenso.
Du, also stand jetzt, wenn dann irgendwann dein ganzer Kader gegen dich spielt, ich glaube, da könnte Fürth noch, dann haben sie ja schon einen neuen Trainer.
Ja, tatsächlich ist es, glaube ich, kein schlechtes Timing, weil ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass Fortuna Düsseldorf sich da jetzt in den Aufwärts-Swirl reingrooved und vor Weihnachten denke ich nicht, dass du einen frisch eingestellten Trainer direkt wieder vor die Tür setzt. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das, wenn sich das fortsetzt, dass das ein sehr fruchtbarer Boden ist. Also ein Fürther fruchtbarer Boden, kein Düsseldorfer fruchtbarer Boden.
Und auch wieder ein Fortuna für alle Spiele. Mal sehen, wie das wird.
Und das verlieren sie ja meistens, wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Aber auch gut, dass da Fürth dann 1 Euro Vorverkaufsgebühr erhebt auf die Freikarten. Aber das ist wieder ein anderes Thema.
Ich glaube, bei uns waren es sogar 5 oder so. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Also das für eine Fußballspiel, das für alle Menschen umsonst sein soll, aufgrund der großen Bearbeitungsgebühren dann immer noch. Gebühren erheben ist auch schön. Aber ich glaube, das führt nach einer Stunde 42 zu weit.
Ich würde jetzt auch zu einem Rent einsetzen, dass ich 42,50 Euro für ein Bochumer Sitzplatz-Ticket bezahlen muss. Das ich sehr frech finde. Aber gut, das ist eine Gali-Grü in den Tief im Westen. Gut, ich würde einfach sagen, wir beenden an der Stelle zumindest schon mal den sportlichen Teil. Ich habe noch ein bisschen Housekeeping für euch. Einmal. Ich habe leider noch kein genaues Datum für euch. Aber die nächste Sendung, die wird kurz vor Weihnachten stattfinden. Es wird einen hinrundenden Rückblick geben mit Marc und mir. Ein bisschen analog zur Vorschau und dem ersten Spieltag. Wir werden nicht jeden Verein in 80 Minuten ungefähr besprechen. Also, weil so viel Zeit habe ich nicht vor Weihnachten. Ich denke mal, wir werden da auch analog wieder die Spiele durchgehen. Also, wenn ihr da Input habt etc., dann bitte rein ins Forum. Gerne auch schon mal sammeln. Sonst natürlich der Hinweis, wie immer, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, payroll- und sponsorenfrei. Der stellvertretende Dank an SupporterInnen geht heute an Jan T., Rasta Ari, René vom Eintracht Podcast, Fried Frank und Jan. Danke, dass ihr bereits Rasenfunk-UnterstützerInnen seid. Wenn ihr mal mehr darüber wissen wollt, dann guckt einfach mal in den Show Notes vorbei. Da sind alle wichtigen Seiten verlinkt. Außerdem ist heute eben die Sendung zur Bundesliga, der Männer erschien, in der Nacht auf Mittwoch. Er scheint, dass die Sendung zum Länderspiel der Frauen, zum Final-Four-Finale, wow, also der Nations League, da geht es ja morgen Abend im Rückspiel gegen Spanien. Und eventuell scheint noch ein Schwerpunkt diese Woche, das soll ich aber auch von Max ausrichten. Das ist noch nicht so ganz klar. Und dann bleibt mir tatsächlich an dieser Stelle nur zu sagen, vielen Dank an meine Gäste, denn zum einen Anna Lautenbach, schön, dass du mit mir, mit uns in dieser Folge dabei warst.
Danke für die Einladung. Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Und ich finde es tatsächlich immer wieder cool, eingeladen zu werden, zu nicht Braunsteig folgen, weil es einfach so die Wahrnehmung der Liga nochmal so ganz anders vertieft. Und das ist echt spannend. Vielen Dank.
Ja, und dann auch lieben Dank an Michi Fischer, der im Chaos dieses Montags, des 1.12., ich hoffe, deine restlichen Türchen des Adventskalenders werden ein bisschen harmonischer. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch harmonischer wird. Aber vielen Dank, dass du dir trotzdem auch für uns die Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Und ich entschuldige mich nochmal für den kurzen gedankliche Chaos in meinem Kopf, was Stefanos Timas angeht. Es tut mir leid, liebe Fans, das 1. FCN ist weg.
Ach ja, den hatte ich ja auch.
Aber der Tag, der war anstrengend heute.
Ihr verzeiht uns das bitte und schaltet dann auch bei der nächsten Folge wieder ein. Ich wünsche euch sonst eine, falls ihr feiert, schöne Adventszeit und wir hören uns dann kurz vor Weihnachten wieder.
Tschüss!
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.